donc nous commençons nos nos travaux de
ce jour par une audition commune sur les
enjeux philosophiques de la fin de vie
je remercie bien évidemment
des personnes que nous auditionnons ce
matin d'avoir accepté cette cette
invitation à venir débattre avec la
commission je précise que cette audition
fait l'objet d'une captation vidéo
retransmée sur le site du Sénat comme
vous le savez notre commission après
avoir entendu le président et les
rapporteurs du Comité consultatif
national d'éthique le CCNE a lancé sa
propre mission d'information relative à
l'évolution de la législation relative à
la fin de vie dans la perspective de
l'examen éventuel du projet de loi qui
pourrait déposer à l'issue des travaux
de la convention citoyenne qui travaille
sur cette thématique
nos rapporteurs Christine bonfantidossa
Corinne Imbert Michel Monnier ont déjà
organisé plusieurs auditions ainsi que
deux déplacements l'un à l'hôpital de la
Pitié-Salpêtrière dans service de
neurologie et l'autre ce lundi même en
Belgique nous sommes allés passer la
journée au regard de l'importance de ce
sujet il me semblait toutefois important
que nous organisions également un cycle
d'audition en plénière et c'est dans ce
cas que nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir madame Monique panto
sperbère une crise de recherche au CNRS
et membre du CCNE Monsieur Bernard Marie
Dupont médecin juriste et professeur
d'éthique médicale monsieur André compte
Sponville philosophe et séisiste et
Monsieur Jacques Ricaud philosophe
chercheur associé au département de
philosophie de l'Université de Nantes
mesdames messieurs je vous propose de
commencer cette audition commune par un
propos liminaire relativement bref je
sais que ce soit tel sujet n'est pas un
exercice forcément très facile afin de
laisser toute leur place aux échanges
qui suivront d'abord à partir des
questions des commissaires que pourront
compléter les rapporteurs si elles le
souhaitent madame je vous passe tout de
suite la parole
à vrai dire je ne traiterai que d'un
point qui a trait à l'ambiguïté morale
de la notion d'aide active à mourir
la loi te laisse Leonetti du 2 février
2016 prévoit une citation profonde et
continue jusqu'au décès pour les malades
qui ont font la demande et qui présente
une affection grave et incurable
causant des souffrances réfractaires au
traitement avec un pronostic vital
engagé à court terme
elle reconnaît ainsi un pllicitement le
droit qui a le malade en fin de vie de
recourir à une aide à mourir sous
supervision médicale
toutefois la loi Leonetti ne s'applique
pas aux personnes qui souffrent de
maladies graves incurables mais dont le
pronostic vital n’est engagé qu'à moyen
terme elle ne concerne pas non plus les
malades dépendants d'un traitement vital
qui ne le supporte plus et veulent
arrêter et qu'ils veulent arrêter avec
une survenue du décès certaines mais
seulement au bout de quelques mots et
souvent dans de grandes souffrances
il arrive que ces personnes dans les
deux cas que je viens de rappeler
demande de façon répétée qu'on les aide
à mourir en dépit de l'accès aux soins
palliatifs dont elle pourrait bénéficier
ce sont là deux cas de fin de vie qui
devraient justifier une évolution de la
législation actuelle
en effet la sédation profonde et
continue que prévoit la loi Leonetti
n'étant envisageable que pour un malade
qui est dans les derniers moments de sa
vie
il s'agit alors si l'on peut dire de
athée la mort qui surviendrait de toute
façon à brève échéance tandis que le
type d'aide à mourir dont il est
question dans les débats actuels une
aide active pour reprendre le terme
couramment employé à mon sens
non à bon escient car la sédation on a
déjà rien d'une aide passive c'est déjà
une forme d'aide active mais en tout cas
l'aide active à mourir dont nous parlons
aujourd'hui dont les débats qui se
tiennent à la Convention citoyenne dans
la société et dans différentes instances
compris dans cette assemblée
a pour but non plus de hâter la mort
mais de provoquer la mort d'un malade
qui n'est pas encore à proprement parler
au terme de sa vie et que quelques mois
encore on sépare
la raison les raisons qu'à une personne
de vouloir abréger sa vie quand la
maladie ne lui laisse aucun espoir de
survie
n'appartiennent qu'à la personne
concernée
en revanche la question de savoir si
dans une si longue de tels cas une aide
pour mourir peut-être permis ce par la
loi
ne peut faire abstraction du système
juridique qui est le nôtre des principes
moraux sur lesquels ces systèmes est
fondé et de la déontologie médicale
c'est un corps indissociable qui forme
ensemble le socle d'une société libérale
dans la mesure où une loi à venir sur
l'aide active à mourir toucherait à une
situation humaine à laquelle de nombreux
Français
il me semble ont été déjà confrontés
dans leur entourage familial ou amical
et à laquelle ils ont sans doute déjà
réfléchi il incombe au législateur me
semble-t-il de justifier sa décision
aussi rigoureusement que possible
et pas seulement on se référant au vote
d'une assemblée représentative de la
population française
deux formes d'aide à mourir sont en
cause dans ce que je viens de dire
d'une part l'assistance au suicide ou
suicide assisté à prédire je n'aime pas
du tout cette expression car il va de
soi qu'il s'agit de malades qui
voudraient vivre
en tout cas ce qu'on appelle suicide
assisté ou à assistance au suicide
consiste à aider une personne à mettre
fin à sa vie sans souffrance on lui
fournissant les moyens de le faire alors
ça peut être un breuvage à avaler c'est
le cas par exemple en Suisse ça peut
être une sonde intestinale à activer ce
qui se pratique en origon dans la mesure
où beaucoup de malades ont fasterminal
de Corse enfin déjà un ça d'avancé de la
maladie même s'ils sont infectablement
phase terminale ne peuvent beaucoup de
difficultés à avaler
il reste que dans ces cas que je viens
d'évoquer la personne jusqu'au dernier
moment c'est à dire jusqu'au moment où
la mort devient réversible et reste
souveraine
il peut donc exprimer
de manière actuelle sa volonté
d'utiliser ses moyens
et également la volonté d'y renoncer in
extremis
par contraste avec ce que je viens de
décrire comme l'assistance au suicide
l'euthanasie consiste dans le fait qu'un
tiers donne la mort à une personne qui
l'a demandé ce tiers étant dans le cas
qui nous occupe un médecin administrant
une injection le plus souvent
et encore le plus souvent quand la
personne est inconsciente et donc plus
on mesure d'exprimer sa volonté au
moment où s'enclin ou s'enclenche le
processus final c'est à dire que celui
qui sera irréversible
la différence entre ces deux types
d'aide et c'est sur ce point que je
voudrais insister à vous dire je n'ai
rien d'autre à dire que cela tient à
ceci le suicide assisté dans le suicide
assisté la personne se reconnaît libre
de ce qu'elle fait d'elle-même jusqu'au
moment
ultime
et que par ailleurs
peu importe c'est improvisé donc la
personne se reconnaît souverain sur ce
qu'il ce qu'elle se fait elle-même
jusqu'au dernier moment et par ailleurs
l'aide qui lui a apporté et qui conduira
à sa mort à savoir volontaire j'insiste
encore sur ce point et est une aide
indirecte c'est-à-dire on donne à la
personne les moyens de mettre fin à ses
jours moyen qu'elle peut utiliser ou pas
utiliser jusque au dernier moment
j'insiste pour sur ce point quand dans
de nombreux cas la substance létale ou
l'activation qu'il faudrait faire de par
la volonté de la personne
ne se fait pas les personnes préfèrent
différé ou préfèrent renoncer tout
simplement
en revanche dans le cas de l'euthanasie
il en est tout autrement d'abord
on peut imaginer bien sûr un état nazie
dans le cas où la personne est
consciente et simplement elle ne peut
plus du tout faire le geste bon ça c'est
un cas qui vaudrait traiter à part mais
dans l'euthanasie ou la personne est
inconsciente qui est vraiment le cas qui
est abordé par le rapport du Comité
national d'éthique et bien dans ce
cas-là il est clair que la personne ne
peut plus au moment où le processus
final s'engage exprimait sa volonté ce
oui je le veux qui est d'une certaine
manière le dernier espace de liberté qui
est le fondement de de l'intégrité de la
personne humaine la possibilité d'être
souverain au dernier moment sur ce qu'on
s'impose à soi-même ou ce qu'on se fait
à soi-même ou ce qui est fait
à son corps et bien n'a plus n'a pas de
lieu d'être et par ailleurs
l'intervention du tiers est une
intervention directe il s'agit
d'administrer la mort alors il me semble
que le fait
les problèmes juridiques qui se posent
en matière d'évolution de la loi sur ces
deux points aussi bien pour l'euthanasie
que pour le suicide assisté sont
considérables pour l'euthanasie c'est
évident on le fait d'administrer la mort
et et considéré dans notre code pénal
comme un assassinat même si la personne
d'ailleurs est consentante puisque ça ne
ça ne consiste pas ça ne constitue pas
un fait justificatif
par ailleurs
les les fondements donc de notre compte
pénal mais également les principaux
fondamentaux sur lesquels ce code est
établi à savoir la prohibition de tuer
qui n'est pas simplement évidemment on
peut on ne peut pas ne pas le rapporter
un héritage religieux mais la plupart
mais l'essentiel de nos systèmes
normatifs et est issu de prescriptions
religieuses qui dans ce cas sont
totalement laïcisés il reste que la
prohibition de tuer est au fond de mot
de la notion d'intégrité personnelle et
de respect de la personne humaine qui
est au cœur de notre conception libérale
je ne peux pas imaginer une société
libre qui apporte la moindre nuance à ce
principe qui est un principe absolu et
fondamental de l'intégrité humaine
et par ailleurs
le fait que
est reconnu une sorte de l'importance
que nos sociétés accorde consentement et
à l'expression
ultime de la volonté est aussi un
principe fondamental que le tanagi a
première vue tel que je l'ai décrite
lorsqu'il s'agit d'administrer la mort à
une principe à une personne inconsciente
peu bafouer alors les choses ne sont pas
très simples que ça pour les suicides
assister non plus puisque le fait de
procurer une personne les moyens de
mettre fin à ses jours
et l'objet d'une jurisprudence qui tente
à considérer cela comme un crime
incontestablement et par ailleurs le
fait de ne pas empêcher une personne de
se servir des moyens de mettre fin à ce
jour est un cas caractérisé de non
d'assistance à personne en danger mais
au moins dans le cas de l'assistance au
suicide est préservée cette souveraineté
de la volonté de la personne sur ce
qu'elle fait de sa vie et cette comme je
l'ai dit c'est ultime espace de liberté
qui lui est laissé au moment au dernier
moment de se servir de ses moyens ou de
ne pas s'en servir
j'insiste sur le point que dans ce que
je viens de dire ce qui peut amener une
personne a décidé
étant donné ce qu'est sa situation
médicale étant donné qu'elle n'a aucune
espérance de survie au-delà de quelques
mois ce qui peut la décider à vouloir
être fin à ses jours n'appartient qu'à
elle de ne peut pas être jugé je ne vais
pas prononcé le moindre jugement moral
là-dessus ça a trait à la sphère la plus
intime la plus personnelle des
engagements de la personne
mais en revanche il me paraît que
préserver l'intégrité de ce moment de
choix ultime est une chose tout à fait
essentielle dont nous sommes
collectivement responsables dont nos
sociétés sont responsables
elle me semble cette ce principe là me
semble en partie
me semblera en partie violet par une loi
à propos de l'euthanasie alors il
m'arrive lorsque j'essaie d'expliquer
cette différence c'est l'importance de
ce oui je le veux prononcer au dernier
moment
d'utiliser deux exemples qui valent ce
qui ce qu'ils veulent évidemment aucun
aucun exemple étant donné le caractère
tout à fait tragique et en quelque sorte
irréductible comme expérience humaine de
ce dont nous parlons ils ne peuvent
valoir son nuance mais le premier
exemple est le suivant il arrive que des
personnes veuillent se marier au dernier
moment au moment pas tellement pour dans
la perspective une vie commune bien sûr
il n'y a aucun avenir devant elle mais
simplement parce que symboliquement
c'est important pour elle que de
contracter une union dans les derniers
moments on ne pourrait pas imaginer
qu'une telle union puisse être
enregistrée indépendante ou officialisée
ou même reçu indépendamment d'une d'une
prononciation de la volonté d'un oui je
le veux prononça prononcer au moment
même où elle est contractée on
imaginerait pas qu'une union soit
prononcée avec la personne est
inconsciente
de même on accepterait pas qu'une
personne puisse changer son testament ou
puissent signer puisque c'est un
document écrit qui est fait faux en la
matière ou puis signer un document pour
lequel elle aurait exprimé pour une
disposition à propos de laquelle elle
aurait exprimé sa volonté et qu'elle
n'aurait pas la manière la possibilité
de reconnaître comme véritablement la
sienne encore une fois par un oui je le
veux dans ce cas ce qu'il a dit
réductible au dernier moment donc si ça
nous est difficile d'imaginer que dans
ces cas-là la volonté de la personne
puisse être déléguée même s'il n'y a
aucun doute sur le fait que c'est ce que
la personne souhaite a fortiori
il ne peut en être question à propos de
l'acte qui met un terme un
à la vie j'assis sur le fait que à mes
yeux ce ne sont pas des distinctions
gazeuses celles que j'ai évidemment
sinon on va pas exprimé celle que je
viens d'exposer mais des éléments qui
sont décisifs dans la conception
libérale de la personne qui souligne son
autonomie sa souveraineté sa liberté
sur les actes qu'il a concernent
donc
reste le cas
difficile en effet d'une personne qui
devenait inconsciente demande à mourir
et qui de met donc dans laquelle
l'équipe médicale le médecin l'équipe
médicale se trouverait
se trouvant confronté à cette situation
déciderait et bien d'accomplir la
volonté de la personne même si elle
n'est pas là pour l'exprimer dans les
derniers moments
dans ce cas là
on peut dire que
incontestablement la responsabilité
médicale serait engagée je ne dois pas
comment une loi pourrait faire
abstraction de de cette dimension là
mais à ce moment-là il est il faudrait
définir des critères précis comme la
demande maintes fois exprimée du patient
qui présente l'acte de thanazi comme le
fait de donner la mort parce qu'il est
impossible de ne pas le faire selon
l'équipe médicale qui s'occupe de la
personne alors le risque de décision
arbitraire évidemment serait écarté
puisque ce très mal à volonté d'un
médecin ou d'un soignant qui appeler qui
donnerait la mort mais une délibération
conduite en commun au sein d'une équipe
médicale mais il reste que cet acte est
un il ne peut pas être un acte considéré
comme
allant de soif alors je fais confiance à
la sagacité des juges pour définir dans
des cas de ce type une forme
d'instruction particulière sans
poursuites sans fonction pénale mais qui
est de façon claire de signaler que il y
a là un type d'acte qui ne peut pas
qu'aucune loi ne peut négalise légaliser
là je pense qu'on n'est pas besoin d'une
loi sur l'euthanasie pour reconnaître et
simplifier ce type de ce type de
situation qui sont réglées de cette
façon là mais qui sont des situations
qui ne sont quand même pas les plus
fréquentes par rapport à celle dont on
vient de parler à savoir la possibilité
d'un suicide assister ou même d'une
telle assise une personne consciente
[Musique]
merci même le président
mesdames les rapporteurs mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs c'est quand même
un plaisir de pouvoir débattre de
manière contradictoire et sereine
sur un sujet
éminemment complexe alors moi je suis
bien entouré puisque au milieu de vous
deux je
j'affirme que il ne faut pas
légaliser
ni des pénaliser pour des raisons que
j'essaye d'expliquer rapidement
sachant que je ne je le précise tout de
suite je ne roule pour aucune chapelle
et aucun parti politique
je suis médecin hématologue je suis prof
d'université
j'ai eu la chance de connaître les soins
palliatifs en Angleterre avec 6lisanders
puis ensuite en France puis ensuite au
Canada
j'en dirai deux mots
parce que à mon avis aussi dans un dans
une société binaire on oppose trop
facilement les bons et les méchants ceux
qui font de la technique et ceux qui
font de l'humain
les Pro est un Asie et les pros seront
palliatifs je pense que le sujet est
éminemment complexe et je m'attarderai
quand même sur la dimension médicale
j'ai été aussi longtemps professeur de
philosophie dans le secondaire et dans
l'enseignement supérieur et la question
de la vérité de
la limite du franchissement
de l'autonomie du sujet ou de son
indépendance parce que parfois une
confusion m'a toujours posé problème
dans une et avec un choix philosophique
qui est un choix essentiellement
conscient c'est-à-dire que je défends
une morale déontologie qui a pas
forcément aujourd'hui bonne presse tu ne
morales exigeante et puis le dernier
point c'est que c'est moindre de mon
activité en tout cas en France et je
suis avocat endommage corporel et
donc je voudrais dire deux mots de la
loi aussi puisque vous avez parlé de la
loi et
si la philosophie n'est pas simple à
manœuvrer la loi non plus on peut on
peut faire dire aux uns et aux autres
plein de choses ce qui me frappe je vais
essayer de faire bref madame le
Président ce qui me frappe dans tous ces
débats qui ont le mérite d'exister en
dépit de leur complexité c'est que très
souvent et trop souvent alors je pars
pas de ce matin et de cette assemblée
c'est qu'on se contente à propos ou de
je sais que où il me semble que et ça
serait mieux là bas et chez nous on fait
mieux et puis là-bas ils font mieux et
nous on fait moins bien bon c'est pas si
simple
quelques repères alors là c'est le
médecin qui parle parce que je trouve
que souvent on est mis en difficulté en
tant que médecin alors même qu'on nous
demande tout et même son contraire on
attend de nous tout
si je regarde simplement le phénomène du
mourir il fut un temps alors je dis pas
que c'était mieux avant c'est pas ce que
j'ai dit certainement pas mais il fut un
temps où l'unité de lieu de temps et
d'action dans la mort était ça c'est ce
que dit Lapalisse avant d'être mort il
était en vie et on avait une situation
où finalement soit on était en vie soit
on faisait le constat du décès c'est à
dire que d'ailleurs il y a des signes
positifs de mort il y a des signes
négatifs de vie c'est-à-dire qu'on avait
une définition de la mort qui était une
mort cardiovasculaire le corps le corps
était arrêté au bout de temps de minutes
on constaté alors on décrit un cercle
aussi c'était relativement sain et c'est
vrai que cet instant complexe du passage
c'est à dire de celui de la vie à la
mort ce qui est une énigme même pour
même encore aujourd'hui en termes de
sciences étaient mis de côté on constaté
la mort voilà bon
sauf que tout bascule en 1953 personne
on en parle lorsque deux internes qui
s'appellent deux internes français
Molare et goulons dans un débat
international rapporte les premiers cas
23 cas de patients qu'ils ont entre
guillemets maintenus en vie alors on
sait pas trop comment à l'époque on sait
pas s'il faut dire maintenant en vie
mais par une ventilation mécanique
c'est-à-dire par un appareillage
extérieur au moment où à l'époque on
avait pas ce système c'est à dire qu'en
fait il y a deux jeunes médecins qui
disent mais attendez la mort c'est pas
si simple parce que aujourd'hui on peut
maintenir avec le cœur sur le cœur par
un appareillage assez simple finalement
c'est le principe tout simple parfois du
défibrillateur mais on peut maintenir en
vie alors on vit point d'interrogation
en tout cas ou en survie mais en tout
cas
le corps va très vite finalement voir un
basculement définition qui me semble un
enjeu décisif qu'on oublie trop
facilement
c'est à dire qu'en quelques années on va
passer de la définition de la mort qui
sera au départ pendant des siècles une
mort cardiovasculaire à une mort
cérébrale c'est-à-dire je vous passe
toutes les étapes intermédiaires mais la
définition enquête parce qu'en fait ça
fait 70 ans c'est extrêmement court en
moins de 70 ans on va voir apparaître
une nouvelle définition de la mort qui
sera une définition de la mort cérébrale
le cœur n'est plus que accessoire est-ce
que vont faire sans le savoir d'ailleurs
au départ molareg ou non c'est qu'ils
vont donner naissance à la réanimation
médicale telle que nous la connaissons
et il faut dire que la réanimation
médicale et donc d'apparition récente
c'est une spécialité médicale
extrêmement récente qui permet
aujourd'hui bien des progrès qui permet
aujourd'hui bien des choses mais c'est
vrai aussi et il faut dire et on en
parle pas assez qui a abouti à produire
des situations médicales qu'on pas
jusqu'à une époque très récente
l'habitude de voir et c'est ce que
j'avais appelé dans un texte un
purgatoire laïque ou un no man's land
c'est à dire qu'on a aujourd'hui des
personnes on a tous des exemples en tête
des exemples mais aussi médiatiques qui
sont plus trop en vie mais pas vraiment
morte qui sont
silencieuses pour pour certaines qui
sont simplement victimes de paralysie
des mi-plégies de tétraplégies pour
d'autres qui seraient plus ou moins
conscientes avec des des altérations
plus ou moins graves et plus ou moins
étagée de dutrons cérébral et
du troncellement
donc il faut avoir conscience d'une fête
de ce fait que nous médecins avons été
mis devant le fait accompli que ces
progrès-là existent et tous les jours
soignent nos proches qu'on sauve d'un
AVC d'un infarctus tout ce que vous
voulez mais qui ont aussi souvent comme
corollaire que
se produisent des situations extrêmement
complexes alors je vais pas faire le
tour de tous les cas de figure que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui mais qui ont
fait hélas parce que c'était un drame
pour ces personnes qui l'ont vécu qui
ont fait la une des médias sans Humbert
Vincent Lambert etc ou on sait tous bon
et ces situations pourraient se
reproduire demain bon donc ça c'est une
réalité donc nous médecins nous sommes
confrontés à ça c'est à dire que il y a
un déplacement de la définition de la
mort un déplacement géographique du cœur
vers le cerveau et puis aussi ce qui me
semble une donnée importante qui est
autant médicale que philosophique c'est
que en maintenant en vie en tout cas on
va dire au moins artificiellement alors
je sais pas s'il faut dire maintenir en
vie maintenir en survie en tout cas en
maintenant en vie pour faire simple on a
remplacé finalement le temps de la mort
par la durée et souvent aussi la durée
d'agonie et donc
la mort n'est plus passage tragique bref
angoissant mais souvent est vécu parce
que c'est aussi une réalité comme un
moment délayé y compris dans les unités
de soins palliatif d'ailleurs ou
finalement on sait plus trop avec des
phases de rémission de bon j'ajoute
aussi que la science pendant ce temps là
à progresser qu'on a rendu chronique un
certain nombre de pathologies qui
étaient jusqu'à une époque très récente
immédiatement mortelle le cancer dans
beaucoup de cas hélas pas dans tous les
cas prix suffisamment tôt etc etc
devient attendant à devenir une maladie
chronique bon donc ça c'est un problème
important j'insiste aussi sur le fait
que
dans notre société occidentale c'est
ainsi c'est comme ça
la mort c'est aussi déplacer
c'est-à-dire qu'elle s'est déplacée soit
vers des hôpitaux soit faire des EHPAD
il y a beaucoup à dire sur les EHPAD
soit sur des plateaux techniques en tout
cas que globalement
alors si je m'en tiens à la France à peu
près trois personnes chez nous sur 4
à de fortes probabilités de décéder dans
une structure de type hôpital c'est à
dire quand même dans une structure avec
plateau technique ou les soignants font
aussi ce qu'ils peuvent mais qui n'est
pas c'est le domicile alors je suis
conscient que le domicile c'est pas
toujours top mais en tout cas on perd
ses repères c'est pas facile une chambre
stérile d'hôpital avec voilà c'est froid
c'est
un côté déshumanisant bon ça c'est aussi
une réalité et puis dans ce que je
voudrais dire aussi en tant que médecin
je suis pas trop long même présent bon
pardon
oui alors vous me faites signe
mais je voudrais corriger voilà en
médecin je voudrais corriger plusieurs
petites choses qui me semblent important
c'est que je trouve curieux quand même
que quand ça marche la médecine on
applaudit et on nous demande plus
guérissez soignez-nous vacciner
découvrez etc etc et puis quand on
met une nouveauté sur la table qui
s'appelle la réanimation médicale qui
peut tout et son contraire on semble
parfois soit nous en vouloir soit nous
accuser de tous les mots nous serions
nous en France Jupiter rien nous aurions
une vision
[Musique]
c'est un peu une provocation
nous serions entièrement verticaux
fermés à tout débat à toute collégialité
c'est vrai que le paternalisme médical a
existé c'est vrai que nous gardons les
réflexes par moment et c'est vrai aussi
que quand on me dit on est allé voir en
Belgique ce qui se passe on est allé
voir en Suisse qui se passe c'est mieux
je réponds simplement la culture
médicale j'ai vécu en Angleterre j'ai
vécu au Canada dans des pays anglophones
ma culture et anglophone ma culture
médicale et anglophone nous avons le
sens de la collégialité horizontale nous
avons en France peut-être que nous
sommes plus latins un principe de
verticalité dans nos hôpitaux le patron
et puis les autres celui qui commande
est celui qui exécute bon c'est comme ça
bon donc ça veut pas dire que c'est
irrémédiable qu'on peut pas changer mais
je tenais aussi à vous le dire qu'on
cesse de nous dire bravo les médecins
faites plus et puis après on le tape
dessus en disant mais qu'est-ce que vous
avez créé là nous avons créé des
situations médicales que nous continuons
de creuser et d'explorer alors je
voudrais
terminer aussi sur la partie médicale
pour dire que
ce qui me semble extrêmement dangereux
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup de traitements
alors vous avez cité la loi néonetti on
a commencé sûrement avant en Angleterre
il y a pas le wallonetti on a commencé
avant et en tant qu’on utilise un
morphine par exemple et même quand j'ai
quitté l'Angleterre en 97 on avait
commencé déjà abandonner la morphine
pour faire des essais avec de la
méthadone c'est-à-dire qu'on se donne
les moyens de faire des expérimentations
bon sous contrôle évidemment on fait pas
n'importe quoi sur le corps humain mais
en tout cas
cette dimension là médicale elle est
réelle et quand on apporte des soins des
personnes en fin de vie sur la sédation
sur la douleur etc etc je vous garantis
en tant que médecin que la frontière est
extrêmement étroite entre la
prescription avisée antalgique et la
prescription a visé pas du tout en
Belgique et que c'est extrêmement
difficile pour l'avocat que je suis là
je parle un tout petit peu l'avocat
ayant une connaissance de l'intérieur
des dossiers médicaux et des
prescriptions que de trouver le point de
rupture entre un choix qui serait fait
avisé par exemple simplement de sédation
comme le prévoir la loi Leonetti et
avisé alors j'entends parler de
l'euthanasie aussi ça c'est attention à
l'utilisation du mot l'euthanasie
suppose quand même aussi dans sa
démarche un accord au moins tacite entre
les deux personnes il y a quand même
quelqu'un qui demande et dans beaucoup
de situations que je vois alors là c'est
en tant qu'avant mais on va dire on
l'oublie ma situation personnelle je ne
trouve pas la demande du patient je ne
trouve pas la demande d'un patient mais
parfois quand je discute avec les
médecins me dis bah toute façon
75 ans 80 ans il y a pas de famille
non non non non non n'auriez pas non ce
sont des choses que j'entends ce sont
des choses que j'entends aussi alors je
ne dis pas tout le monde est cette
démarche mais c'est aussi une réalité
qu'il faut entendre c'est à dire que il
est extrêmement facile de franchir la
limite sans que je puisse réellement
démontrer des intentions homicides qui
pourtant parfois sont réelles je ne dis
pas que tous les soignants ont cette
intention alors
je voudrais vraiment terminer là-dessus
après il y aura des questions mais
je pense que c'est mon point de vue
confronté à l'euthanasie en tant
qu'acteur
en tant que praticien soins palliatif
j'ai eu la c'est ainsi j'ai fait
beaucoup de soins palliatifs en
pédiatrie et j'ai vu beaucoup d'enfants
mourir mais pas seulement je peux dire
que sur des années de pratique et encore
une fois je ne roule pour personne je
n'ai pas je n'appartiens à aucun parti
même si je vote mais je n'appartiens
aucune structure c'est ma réflexion
basée sur l'expérience je peux dire que
sur les dizaines voire les centaines de
personnes que j'ai pu
assister entre guillemets pratiquement
toujours il y avait une souffrance
existentielle c'est-à-dire philosophie
c'est-à-dire que l'angoisse devant la
fin de vie est réelle le deuxièmement je
pense que on demande aux soignants une
réponse médicale à une question
philosophique le problème il est pas
philosophique d'abord pardon il est pas
médical ni juridique d'abord il est
existentiel c'est à dire le sens de la
vie le sens du passage ma mort l'instant
de ma mort jean-kevitch etc c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est pour moi
qui dépasse largement le cadre et du
droit et de la médecine et puis je
voudrais dire aussi pour tordre le coup
hélas un certain nombre de choses que
qu'on soit du côté des personnes qui
veulent un droit à mourir et qui milite
dans des associations ou du côté des
soins palliatifs on ne solutionne pas
tout seul dans son coin le problème
c'est à dire qu'on continue d'avoir en
soins palliatifs des peurs des ang
et que voilà on peut pas opposer je
crois qu'il faut sortir de cette
opposition les uns et les autres et
alors sur la question du droit aussi
pour en terminer et je vous donnerai ma
position en une minute je pense que le
si vous voulez lire ce qui a été alors
c'est bizarre en France on commente la
maladie française d'ailleurs en
philosophie aussi vous savez bien on
commente sur des commentaires mais on
lit pas le texte on lit pas les
philosophes mais on préfère les
commenter
le texte a été écrit par le doyen
Bernard renié professeur de droit civils
à Toulouse dans le juris classeur civil
70 et remarquable il est l'aboutissement
de ce que endroit on peut dire de
l'éventuelle légalisation de
l'euthanasie et je vous livre simplement
sa conclusion parce que ça serait trop
long la mort en tant que tel doit rester
un phénomène à préfixe privatif
juridique
ma position est la suivante pour
vraiment terminer je pense que
personnellement en tant que praticien
des soins palliatifs c'est-à-dire qu'en
ayant une vision concrète des choses
d'ailleurs je parle pas en l'air en
disant oui il faudrait il y a 4 etc oui
tout ça je suis d'accord mais en même
temps qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur le
terrain qu'est-ce qu'on fait confronter
à la souffrance au manque de place à la
génération babyboom qui demement arrive
au fait que dans les EHPAD il y a une
place à peu près pour 10 personnes en
attente le fait que aussi on a des
maladies neurodégénératives qui arrivent
alors tout simplement alors pas que des
Alzheimer il y en a mais pas que dsla on
parle des maladies Charcot mais bien sûr
il y en a mais il y en a toujours eu
mais aussi tout simplement le fait de
vieillir nous sommes entrés dans un
monde c'est comme ça mécaniquement ou le
corps humain vieillit alors on peut s'en
réjouir je ne sais pas s'il fait de
vieillir
ne dis pas forcément vieillir en bonne
santé et dans de bonnes conditions qui
est un vrai problème politique mais en
tout cas c'est sûr qu'on va avoir dans
nos hôpitaux dans nos domicile dans nos
territoires je suis un homme de la
province la difficulté à se faire
soigner à trouver des structures à
trouver des médecins à trouver des
Hôpitaux dignes de ce nom bon qu'est-ce
qui va se passer demain avec nos
personnes âgées il y a déjà beaucoup de
situations où on en fait quoi et un
certain nombre de camarades promotion
moi je fais matlogue qui sont gériates
me disent pourquoi tu t'embêtes à
pourtant ils sont pas des voyous
j'espère pourquoi tu t'embêtes à
défendre à empêcher une légalisation il
y a un candidat pour il y a un lit
plutôt pour 10 candidats ça fera
toujours un peu de place donc mon
problème à moi en tant que médecin c'est
que demain je sais qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs il est en dépit de la loi
Leonetti il est extrêmement facile de
faire disparaître quelqu'un sans sans
lui-même lui avoir demandé son avis
c'est extrêmement facile et je vous mets
au défi de m'emmener devant les
tribunaux et de prouver que ce que j'ai
fait était alors non pas un acte de
tanaisie puisque de toute façon le
patient parfois n'en n'a pas n'a pas
demandé mais alors quoi il y a pas
d'incrimination pénale spécifique pour
le tanazi c'est à dire un meurtre un
assassinat un crime bon ça il faudrait
voir la notion d'intention etc etc mais
en tout cas c'est extrêmement facile et
ma crainte à moi c'est que demain
si on l'égalise c'est le principe de Mai
68 à partir du moment où tout est
autorisé il y a plus d'interdit et ce
qui me semble beaucoup plus fort ce qui
me semblerait plus fort c'est ce
qu'avait dit le CCNE dans la vie 63 de
janvier 2000 qui est à mon sens alors on
n'est pas tous d'accord là-dessus et
était déjà un aboutissement maintenir
l'interdit fondamentale du donner la
mort pour des raisons médicales mais
envisager alors le CCNE nous encourager
à le penser une structure qui
permettrait d'envisager les exceptions
mais le principe une exception reste une
exception et je peux vous garantir que
sur toute ma pratique médicale je sais
pas si je dis j'ai oublié de le dire je
crois que je peux dire réellement que
j'ai vu deux cas dont un aujourd'hui
aurait disparu deux personnes qui
réellement pouvaient demander
légitimement le Tati pour moi en droit
je terminerai là-dessus l'exception
confirme la règle mais on ne base pas
une règle sur une exception et
je répondrai à ma madame canto sperbère
avec laquelle je suis souvent d'accord
que je suis en désaccord sur un point
l'autonomie n'est pas l'indépendance le
droit est un principe d'obligation qui
engage les deux parties dire j'ai c'est
ma liberté fondamentale de dire je veux
mourir oui je peux le dire et par contre
ma demande mon choix
il engage aussi la partie adverse il
engage l'équipe soignante c'est à dire
je suis pas indépendant je fais pas ce
que je veux ça je le crois à 10 12 ans
15 ans ouais je vais faire ce que je
veux non je fais pas
bien bonjour à tous merci de m'avoir
invité
écoutez je suis venu vous offrir un
livre
dont je suis l'auteur
qui s'appelle La Clé des champs et
autres imprompus c'est un recueil
d'articles 12 articles le premier seul
concerne notre débat puisqu'il porte sur
le tanasie et le suicide assisté
j'ai deux observations sur ce livre
d'abord le titre effectivement un clin
d'oeil à Montaigne la clé des champs
Montaigne écrit dans les essais le plus
beau cadeau que nature nous est fait
c'est de nous avoir laissé la clé des
champs la clé des champs c'est-à-dire le
droit de s'en aller et en effet je crois
comme Montaigne et Montaigne croyait le
dit lui-même comme tous les anciens les
Grecs les latins
et aujourd'hui comme la plupart des
penseurs non religieux je crois en effet
que le droit de mourir y compris
volontairement fait partie des droits de
l'homme
comme j'aurais peu le temps Faudel plein
d'arguments sur je vous renvoie à cet
article dont je peux pas l'offrir à tout
le monde le livre malheureusement mais
vous pouvez le photocopier madame la
Présidente ça ne fait que 15 pages
ça ne fait que 15 pages et je l'assume
parce que ce n'est pas un sujet
tellement important
le droit de mourir fait partie des
droits de l'homme mais quand même
beaucoup moins important que le droit de
vivre
et beaucoup plus facile à assurer et
donc que le Sénat se préoccupe de la
question comment donner les moyens de
vivre dignement à nos concitoyens ça ça
relève d'un travail très très compliqué
très très difficile
à côté le droit de mourir c'est d'une
assez grande simplicité me semble-t-il
donc c'est pas très important c'est pas
très compliqué moi j'étais membre du
Comité consultatif national d'éthique au
début de l'année 2000 si tu restais 8
ans on a eu à débat de la fin de vie je
connais tous les arguments c'est les
mêmes aujourd'hui c'était les mêmes il y
a 20 ans je n'ai jamais entendu un
nouvel argument depuis 15 ans montrait
bien
c'est pas si compliqué que ça même si
juridiquement ça peut être plus
compliqué moi je ne suis pas juriste je
ne suis que philosophe mais voilà c'est
pas l'action est plus importante le
droit de vivre est plus important que le
droit de mourir
la mort volontaire c'est pas du tout la
liberté suprême comme certains
prétendent c'est la liberté ultime mais
par définition le team mais dès qu'on
aime la liberté on a envie d'être libre
jusqu'au bout et jusqu'au bout ça peut
supposer parfois
la mort volontaire
et donc ce n'est pas du tout malgré ce
qu'a dit notre président de la
République personnage pour lequel je
tiens à le préciser par le temps qui
courent j'ai le plus grand respect mais
ça n'est pas en l'occurrence le grand
combat entre Éros est un Athos la
formule m'a un peu inquiétée dans la
bouche du Printemps de la République
parce que ça laisse entendre qui avait
d'un côté donc Eros la pulsion de vie
chez Freud Thanatos la pulsion de mort
évoqué à propos de la fin de vie le
grand combat entre eros est anatos ça
pourrait laisser entendre je ne dis pas
que c'est ce que le connard vit dans la
tête mais ça pourrait laisser entendre
qu'il y a d'un côté ceux qui sont pour
la mort et donc favorable l'euthanasie
et de l'autre ceux qui sont pour la vie
et donc opposés à l'euthanasie mais bien
sûr que non personne n'est pour la mort
tout le monde et pour la vie simplement
il se trouve que nous sommes tous et
pour la vie et pour la liberté
et du coup la question de pouvoir mettre
librement fin à sa propre vie est une
question ouverte et personnellement je
pense effectivement que le droit d'y
mettre fin fait partie des droits de
l'homme
et quand je disais que ça n'est pas si
important
au total j'ai dû beaucoup sur la mort et
j'écris pas mal mais c'est surtout
beaucoup lu sur la mort je crois que ce
que je connais de mieux c'est un
alexandrin de Mallarmé dans son art
poétique ma l'armée écrite se peut
profond ruisseau calomnie la mort ce peu
profond ruisseau calomnier la mort mais
oui la mort c'est pas un océan infini
c'est presque rien presque rien puisque
enfin en tout cas pour moi qui suis
athée la mort c'est rien voir moins que
rien comme disait Lucrèce c'est le néant
et donc voilà ce peu profond ruisseau
calomnieux la mort je demande simplement
à avoir le droit d'en décider moi-même
dans certaines circonstances
bien sûr mais enfin me suicider c'est
pas si facile que ça moi j'ai pas de
revolver chez moi souvenez-vous de
Gilles de jeux le philosophe s'ouvre à
70 ans souffrant d'une insuffisance
respiratoire extrêmement grave n'en
pouvant plus voulant en finir la seule
façon que Gilles Deleuze a trouvé pour
en finir ça a été de se jeter par la
fenêtre du cinquième étage où il
habitait lequel d'entre nous se
souhaitent à lui-même ou à ses proches
une mort pareil
enfin bon c'est vrai je peux me sauter
de la fenêtre moi j'habite au 6e étage
des centres de me rater sont limités oui
je peux et je suis en bonne santé mais
tant que je suis en bonne santé pourquoi
voulez-vous que je me suicide c'est
idiot moi j'aime la vie j'ai envie que
ça dure le plus longtemps possible mais
imaginez que ce soir j'ai eu un AVC ça
fait pour moi le quatrième entre nous
soit dit je me trouve à l'hôpital ou
dans un EHPAD et bien essayez de vous
suicider dans un EHPAD ou dans un
hôpital vous m'en direz des nouvelles
c'est impossible or c'est justement là
que je pourrais avoir envie pour de
bonnes raisons de me suicider pas quand
je suis en bonne santé mais quand je
suis malade dépendant sauf que c'est
justement quand je peux avoir de bonnes
raisons de vouloir mourir que je ne peux
plus le faire moi-même et que donc j'ai
besoin de l'aide de quelqu'un je trouve
que l'aide de mon médecin si il est
conscience j'y reviendrai et quand même
ce qui paraît le plus naturel
voilà et puis à l'écart on peut pas
effectivement du tout y compris jeune
parfois souvenez-vous de Vincent Imbert
donc ce jeune homme de 20 ans paralysé
des quatre membres aveugle mais ne point
plus bouger je crois que le pouce de la
main gauche si je me souviens bien
qui supplie sa mère de l'aider à mourir
j'aurais fait comme lui j'aurais fait
comme elle pour ma part j'oublie ce
personne à en faire autant mais moi si
le jeune Vincent Imbert avait voulu
vivre il fallait tout faire pour donner
les moyens de vivre le mieux possible le
moins mal possible mais dès lors qu'il
voulait mourir de quel droit lui
interdire de le faire
n'était pas en fin de vie il ne relevait
pas de la loi leonétique il avait 20 ans
espérance de vie 65 ans
est-ce que c'est une raison pour
l'empêcher de mourir
mon ami Roland jacquard journaliste mon
premier éditeur c'est suscité à 80 ans
j'ai dîné avec lui un mois avant sa mort
c'est le dîner le plat des idées les
plus chaleureux les plus gaies les plus
tendes que j'ai vécu de ma vie
il était pas handicapé commençait à
avoir mal au genou il vieillissait elle
avait peur de devenir Alzheimer je
pensais qu'il avait assez vécu il a
décidé d'en finir comment lui il a eu la
chance il a pas eu à se jeter par la
fenêtre il m'a l'une des raisons de sa
joie quand on a dîné ensemble ce dernier
repas il m'a dit écoute je suis très
content un ami mexicain m'a donné enfin
la substance létale qui me permettra de
mourir quand je l'aurais décidé
tant mieux pour lui mais tout le monde
n'a pas un ami mexicain plutôt que
chercher un ami au Mexique je préfère
pouvoir demander l'aide de mon médecin
et puis il y a la maladie d'Alzheimer
moi mon père est mort Alzheimer quand il
a plus pu vivre chez lui dans le petit
pavillon de banlieue et les Pittet sa
femme a trouvé un deux pieds dans une
maison de retraite pas n'est pas d'une
autre retraite tout à fait normale assez
chic même ils avaient un peu d'argent
sauf que quand mon père est entré
j'étais avec eux pour visiter ce deux
pièces j'entends mon père murmuré je
préférerais crever
je préférerais crever j'ai été un peu
lâche j'ai fait semblant de ne pas
entendre
de se déshydrater on le met sous
perfusion
et on lui a offert entre 5 et 10 ans je
ne sais plus bien d'hospitalisation au
service de gérontologie de l'hôpital de
Vaugirard moi j'ai trois enfants si je
peux éviter à mes enfants le poids
énorme la souffrance les soucis d'avoir
un père Alzheimer pendant 5 ou 10 ans
mais bien sûr que je préfère mourir
alors c'est une question difficile mais
le droit au suicide fait partie des
droits de l'homme y compris quand on a
les premiers signes une maladie
d'Alzheimer ça suppose bien sûr deux
choses d'abord il faudra évidemment une
clause de conscience de telle sorte
qu'aucun médecin aucun soignant ne soit
jamais obligé de donner la mort à
quiconque ni d'aider qui donc à mourir
si c'est contraire à ses valeurs morales
ou religieux on a fait cette clause de
conscience pour la loi Veil concernant
l'IVG et bien loin que c'est empêché la
légalisation du l'IVG c'est ce qu'il a
rendu possible
je vois pas pourquoi il en irait
autrement de ce que j'appelle l'IV et
l'interruption volontaire de vie donc il
faudra bien sûr une clause de conscience
de ce point de vue personne ne vous
obligera cher Monsieur à tuer qui compte
deuxième précision il faut bien sûr
distinguer là je rejoins Monique il faut
bien sûr distinguer le succès d'assister
et le temps nazi la différence c'est que
dans le sida assisté je prends moi-même
le comprimé la substance est à le
breuvage létal qui mettra fin ma vie où
j'appuie moi-même sur la pente qui
actionne la perfusion qui m'enverra le
produit létal dans les veines ou les
artères alors que l'euthanasie c'est un
tiers le plus souvent un médecin qui
accomplit l'acte l'État c'est pas du
tout la même chose
parce que les médecins me disent souvent
j'ai pas fait médecine pour tuer les
gens bah oui je le comprends bien je
suis pas idiot et c'est vrai qu'entre
vous et nous c'est jeudi s'agissant
d'euthanasie nous ne sommes pas du même
côté de la seringue parce que pour nous
les patients l'euthanasie éventuellement
ou le chez l'assister c'est un service
qu'on demande s'il vous plaît rendez-moi
service mettez fin à ses souffrances oui
mais pour le médecin le soignant c'est
pas un service c'est lui qui pousse la
seringue c'est pas un service c'est un
homicide et je comprends tout à fait que
vous soyez pour le moins réticent et
donc dans tous les cas où le Cid ou le
suicide assisté est possible et bien sûr
le patient veut se suicider
il faut bien sûr privilégier le suicide
assisté
par rapport à l'euthanasie parce que ça
évite de faire porter à un tiers cet
acte d'homicide or c'est presque
toujours possible il faut vraiment être
extrêmement limité pour pas faut voir
avaler un comprimé boire un breuvage ou
appuyer sur la pompe qui envoie le
produit létal dans la perfusion
c'est pas un médecin mais je pense ça va
être de 90% 95% des cas le patient peut
lui-même absorber le produit létal c'est
donc n'ont pas eu l'euthanasie mais un
succès d'assister il se trouve qu'il y a
quelques cas où c'est impossible le cas
du jeune Vincent Imbert m'en a pourra en
trouver d'autres qui pour peu nombreux
qu'ils soient en proportion doivent
quand même représenter plusieurs
centaines de cas par an dans un pays
comme le nôtre qui requierait pour le
coup légitimement l'euthanasie auquel
cas et donc je pense qu'il faut
légaliser les deux et le Sud assister et
l'euthanasie mais en indiquant que dans
tous les cas où les deux sont possibles
techniquement si je veux dire il faut
bien sûr privilégier sans aucune
hésitation le suicide assisté
j'ajouterai que je n'attends pas une loi
consensuelle parce qu'il y a pas de loi
consensuelles souvenez-vous de la loi
veille alors si la loi qui n'était pas
consensuelle au moment de son vote c'est
bien la loi veille
et pour des raisons que je comprends
parce qu'entre le se dit le problème
moral de l'avortement est infiniment
plus grave que le problème moral du Sud
assister parce qu'il s'agit de soi
simplement
sauf que Montaigne écrit dans les essais
je cite de mémoire et approximativement
mais quand je prends de l'argent dans ma
bourse
je ne suis pas coupable de vol c'est mon
argent
quand je brûle mon bois dans ma cheminée
je ne suis pas un incendiaire c'est mon
bois c'est ma cheminée et donc quand je
mets fin à ma vie je ne suis pas un
meurtrier
et c'est pourquoi la question du suicide
fait partie effectivement des libertés
non pas suprême encore une fois mais des
libertés ultimes donc ça ne t'a pas de
consensus pour ce qui est de cette loi
que je souhaite j'attends un apaisement
et là je dirais que la loiveille est
très éclairante rappelez-vous le climat
de tension de drame est injustice la vie
de Madame Bay dans lequel ce débat s'est
formulé
non on n'est toujours pas d'accord sur
cette voie veille beaucoup de gens très
respectables sont opposés à l'avortement
et y compris à la légalisation de
l'avortement la dépénalisation de
l'avortement
le consensus n'est pas réalisé mais le
débat est apaisé voilà maintenant ma
connaissance quasiment personne en
France a parmi les personnes les plus
participant au débat public les parmi
les républicains disons se connaît très
très peu de gens qui demandent
l'abolition de la loi belge
ne cherchons pas un consensus mais
cherchons un apaisement et je crois
qu'une loi légalisant et la fin de vie
par les Cadiens pardon et l'euthanasie
et le seul système loi par définition
non consensuelles quand il sera voté
mais pourra favoriser un apaisement que
pour ma part je souhaite je vous
remercie
merci et pour terminer Monsieur Rico
ensuite on passera aux questions
merci madame la Présidente et merci
madame monsieur le rapporteur merci les
sénateurs merci de nous offrir la
possibilité à nous quatre de dialoguer
le dialoguer parce que finalement les
occasions existent mais elles ne se
concrétise pas comme il le faudrait je
dis cela parce que il m'est arrivé de
rencontrer André couteau Sponville en
coloc nous avons traité l'un et l'autre
par exemple de la question du suicide il
m'est arrivé de lire Monique Antho
sperbère j'ai lu aussi
mon collègue Bernard Marie Dupont
et j'admire beaucoup les travaux des uns
et des autres et je regrette
profondément que nous n'ayons pas
vraiment l'occasion de poser
paisiblement sur la table sereinement
comme c'est le cas dans une enceinte
comme celle-ci les arguments d'hiver
pour ma part
je tiens à signaler que je ne suis
évidemment pas soignant je ne suis que
philosophe
encore moins légers ce sont deux
fonctions extraordinairement complexes
que celle là mais depuis 30 ans un peu
plus même je fréquente de façon quasi
hebdomadaire les services hospitaliers
les services de soins palliatifs j'étais
pendant 17 ans membres du comité
d'éthique du CHU de ma ville de Nantes
ma bonne ville de Nantes donc j'ai le
meunier fait partie aussi je
rencontre donc les personnes en fin de
vie étant moi-même bénévole
d'accompagnement je rencontre beaucoup
les soignants et j'apprends énormément
leurs contacts pendant 8 ans je me suis
interdit de prendre la parole
publiquement ou d'écrire quoi que ce
soit sur cette question qui était déjà
dans les années 90 fort idéologisé et il
m'a fallu fréquenter les services
revertir parfois la blouse blanche pour
commencer à oser balbutier un certain
nombre de
choses que j'avais apprises du côté de
ceux qui sont au contact régulier
quotidiens de ces personnes qui arrivent
en fin de vie
il m'a fallu 8 ans pour rentrer je crois
dans la complexité du sujet
et
j'aimerais vraiment que tous ceux qui
aujourd'hui parlent haut et fort fasse
cette même expérience j'allais dire
d'humilité qui consiste pas seulement à
examiner des arguments mais à connaître
de l'intérieur ce qui se joue dans cette
alliance thérapeutique si singulière si
étrange et qui finalement est de loin
pour moi la source
d'enrichissement et d'instruction la
plus forte
c'est pas la première fois que
les parlementaires m'invitent à
réfléchir avec eux et je me permettrai
quelque chose d'indiscret j'ai
énormément appris de la part de deux
d'entre eux
avec lesquels je suis resté en contact
d'une part le député de droite Jean
Leonetti et d'autre part le député de
gauche Parti communiste français Michel
vaccès il est mort en 2014 nous étions
en accord
absolu complet sur ces questions ou
lui-même parlait de rupture
civilisationnelle quand il s'agissait de
légaliser le fait de donner la mort
évidemment je veux pas me donner la
facilité ayant parlé après les autres de
reprendre un à un tel ou tel argument
que j'ai entendu auparavant mais enfin
je ne vois pas comment une société peut
instituer un droit de l'homme qui serait
le droit au suicide là je reconnais que
les bras mentaux de philosophiquement et
juridiquement c'est une liberté bien
entendu celle que Montaigne au nord par
ses beaux textes sur la clé des champs
c'est une liberté individuelle comme
dirait les juristes mais ce n'est pas un
droit un droit nous fait muter de monde
nous ne sommes plus du tout dans le même
registre j'ai beaucoup apprécié
tout à l'heure d'avoir entendu cette
différence éthique parce qu'on est fait
elle est très forte entre le geste
euthanasique et le geste qui consiste à
fournir un poison mortel à quelqu'un
ces deux cas différents je suis bien
content d'avoir entendu complètement
ville André gontesponville le dire aussi
parce que j'avais cru lire parfois que
pour lui
l'euthanasie c'était pas autre chose que
l'aide
moi la formule quelque part
l'euthanasie n'est qu'une assistance
médicale au suicide c'est parce que j'ai
entendu tout à l'heure et je m'en
réjouis ça n'est pas la même chose ce
n'est pas la même chose ça ne pose pas
le même type de de problème j'en veux
pour preuve moi qui était la semaine
dernière en visioconférence avec les
médecins autrichiens qui viennent depuis
un an de légaliser le suicide assisté je
viens de d'en avoir le témoignage et la
preuve que c'était pas du tout la même
chose parce que aujourd'hui non
seulement les médecins mais aussi la
société autrichienne tout entière est
tout à fait hostile à une légalisation
de l'euthanasie ils admettent le suicide
assisté mais il refuse avec la dernière
énergie
qu'il s'agisse aussi d'euthanasie y
compris dans des cas extrêmes où la
personne n'aurait pas les moyens
elle-même de porter le poison mortel à
sa bouche c'est d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe aussi dans les 10 ou 11 États des
États-Unis qui aujourd'hui ont légalisé
le suicide assisté le médecin était
épargné de ce genre
de gestes létal on ne lui demande pas de
le faire et même et s'il le faisait
d'ailleurs il serait sanctionné par les
tribunaux
l'euthanasie et le fils de la cité c'est
pas du tout la même chose parce que
c'est pas la même dynamique qui
s'installe je vous recommande de lire le
dernier article dans mars avril
de la revue du droit de la santé
l'article de Yves Méric doublet qui
montre très clairement que le suicide
assisté
concerne 0,6% des cas de mort assisté
donc en Oregon alors que dans des pays
qui ont légalisé l'euthanasie il y en a
pas beaucoup
Canada Benelux Espagne
du côté de l'Océanie c'est un peu plus
compliqué dans ces pays là
même si on centenait au chiffre officiel
on est dans des proportions 4 à 5 fois
plus élevées d'euthanasie et même si on
tient compte et on devrait tenir compte
des euthanasies qui ne sont pas déclarés
dans ces pays on arrive à 7 à 8 fois
plus de cas d'euthanasie de suicide
autrement dit c'est pas du tout la même
dynamique qui se produit selon l'une ou
l'autre des législations et il me semble
que cela doit être bien rappelé
alors le
point que j'aimerais traiter ou plutôt
les points que j'aimerais traiter
sont deux
d'abord m'interroger sur la notion de
soin qu'est-ce que soigner veut dire et
ensuite devant une assemblée comme la
vôtre je le fais timidement mais
qu'est-ce que faire la loi veut dire
qu'est-ce qu'un législateur
d'abord
l'euthanasie est un soin je l'entendis
et les bras montants tombent parce que
il me semble qu'entre philosophe de
bonne volonté nous devrions au moins
nous entendre sur le vocabulaire sur le
lexique que nous utilisons
je suis très reconnaissant sur le site à
nouveau à mon voisin André
comtosponville d'avoir
osé publiquement dénoncer l'usage
falsificateur du mot de dignité dans
cette affaire comme il le dit très très
bien ça n'est pas une affaire de dignité
c'est une affaire de liberté et en effet
ça clarifie sa simplifie le débat
arrêtons d'utiliser ce mot de dignité
pour dire qu'il y aurait des mordides et
d'autres qui ne le seraient pas mais où
va-t-on
en revanche il me semble que il y a un
accord un consensus à obtenir sur le
lexique je crois qu'il y a non pas
simplement un problème lexicographique
mais il y a un problème d'éthique du
lexique quand on utilise des mots aussi
forts que le mot de soigner
l'euthanasie est-elle un soin le soin
médical alors je laisse de côté la
question du suicide assisté ici le soin
médical chacun conviendra c'est guérir
quand c'est possible et soulager
toujours je le dis d'une formule très
ramassée pour que au moins on rentre pas
dans la complexité de celle de
l'Organisation Mondiale de la Santé qui
est d'ailleurs à mon avis tout à fait
parfaite en son genre et qui d'ailleurs
indique que justement de la façon la
plus claire que donner la mort n'est pas
un soin ça c'est il faudra si un jour on
dit ça il faudra quand même demander le
MS de réviser un peu sa définition ce
que je ne souhaite pas
pourquoi est-ce que l'euthanasie n'est
pas un soin
et bien d'abord parce que elle ne
complète pas l'accompagnement elle
l'arête
elle ne succède pas aux soins palliatifs
elle les interrompt
elle ne soulage pas le patient elle
élimine soulager la souffrance ça n'est
pas faire disparaître le souffrant j'ai
ma cité Bernanos dans son livre
anti-franquis Le Cimetière sous la lune
où il disait exactement ça de façon très
prémonitoire dès 1938
il voyait à se dessiner devant nous dans
un même
propre finalement et la souffrance et le
souffrant
vous avez peut-être vu comme moi
le texte signé par très organisation
qui ont la particularité c'était le mois
de février dernier qui ont la
particularité d'être de rassembler des
soignants qui sont au contact régulier
de la fin de la vie je dis ça parce que
il y a des contrepétitions mais regardez
bien elles sont signées par des
rhumatologues des offres des
ophtalmologues bref par des gens qui
n'ont pas ce contact régulier donc on
peut soupçonner un petit brin
d'idéologie
c'est très organisation qui représente
800 000
soignants sont unanimes pour dire que ça
n'est pas un soin et ils adressent cette
supplie que je voudrais vous lire
laissez le monde du soin à l'écart de
tout implication dans une forme de mort
administrée c'est à contredit leur
métier et sa contredit leur vocation ça
contredit le sens qu'ils essaient de
donner à leur fonction une légalisation
d'une forme de mort médicalement
administrée et Christine emporterait une
modification essentielle de l'éthique
soignante en changeant le sens du mot
soin et bien
disciple de Socrate je crois qu'il faut
être très attentif les uns et les autres
et que nous soyons philosophes de
métiers ou non au sens des mots que nous
utilisons
le soin ne doit pas être modifié dans
une équipe qu'il s'agisse d'un geste
compassionnel ou fait en conscience par
un médecin c'est une chose mais
n'appelons pas soin de grâce que le
législateur n'appelle pas soin ce qui
contredit le soin ce qui est autre que
le soin ce qui est différent du soin ce
qui est l'aveu d'une difficulté d'une
impasse peut-être d'une aporie d'une
impuissance même mais n'appelons pas
soin je vous en supplie en tant que
législateur si vous deviez faire évoluer
la loi n'appelait pas soin ce geste là
vous seriez en train de changer
de fond en comble le sens de ce métier
où vous le savez bien il est si
difficile aujourd'hui
de recruter et aussi d'accompagner et de
former
j'apprécie évidemment que la clause de
conscience spécifique soit envisagée si
jamais l'évolution législative devait
être celle que certains souhaitent que
beaucoup souhaitent même
mais je me permets de préciser quelque
chose ici la clause de conscience c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose que
l'objection de conscience c'est que vous
la trouvez dans le code de déontologie
l'article 47 et qui concerne tout un
chacun tous les soignant bien sûr pour
des raisons personnelles ou
professionnelles peuvent se refuser à
poser un acte mais la clause de
conscience franchir pas de plus ne
serait-ce que sur le plan juridique
d'ailleurs elle n'a pas la même
solennité la clause de conscience dépend
du législateur le code de déontologie
dépend puisque ce sont des décrets
indépendants davantage d'une initiative
gouvernementale donc c'est plus fragile
donc maintenez bien cette clause de
conscience et je crois que cela n'est
pas discuté par personne en ce moment
n'est pas contesté par
mais je forme un autre jeu
j'étais la semaine dernière
invitée par les responsables de 40
épingles et autres établissements
médico-sociaux
c'est pas des religieux c'est pas des
droites gauche c'est tout simplement des
gens de terrain et il me disait mais
j'espère bien que non seulement la
clause de conscience sera individualisée
mais qu'elle s'appliquera aussi à nos
institutions parce que ça fait partie de
notre charte quand nous accueillons
quelqu'un de toujours lui dire ta vie
compte et nous n'avons pas tant de
demandes que cela qui persiste elles ont
rarissime
je disais que j'étais en lien très
régulier depuis si longtemps avec le
personnel soignant le responsable je le
nomme de la mélodie de Charcot à
Bordeaux me disait il y a trois semaines
364 un seul un seul à persister à
demander l'euthanasie donc la question
cela me touche beaucoup et c'est là
parce que moi aussi je peux raconter la
fin de vie de mon père en train
d'Alzheimer je peux raconter aussi il y
a un mois le décès de la meilleure amie
de ma fille qui est justement d'une
maladie de Charcot d'une SMA et je peux
témoigner pour connaître un peu
mieux que beaucoup je crois ces
situations je peux témoigner que c'est
beaucoup plus rare mais évidemment comme
ça arrive les médias s'en emparent et
est-ce au législateur de se laisser
impressionner intimider par le discours
médiatique qui évidemment ici va
toujours dans le même sens celui du
spectacle celui aussi de l'émotion
alors j'ai dit que j'allais parler aussi
de la loi alors je ne veux pas ici faire
la leçon au législateur que vous êtes je
pense que votre métier est difficile
qu'il est très noble en même temps mais
je déclinerai simplement trois quatre
affirmations premièrement le droit pénal
n'a pas qu'une fonction répressive il a
aussi une fonction expressive et
symbolique et à ce titre il traduit les
valeurs d'une société
et donc
est-il bien utile de toujours céder à ce
que dentaire avait appelé un jour la
fureur de légiférer n'est-il pas aussi
grand aussi noble de dire que le droit
doit s'abstenir en certaines
circonstances en certaines situations
j'ai eu le plaisir tout à l'heure à
entendre citer le doyen baigné et en
effet le doyen baigné m'a beaucoup
instruit moi ce que si j'ai appris
énormément des médecins des infirmières
et surtout des aides-soignantes je dois
le dire au passage
j'ai appris énormément aussi de ma
fréquentation assidue des virus des
juristes et le doyen baigné justement
disent mais s'agissant du suicide le
droit s'abstient c'est une liberté c'est
une possibilité c'est une éventualité ça
n'est pas un droit c'est à dire que ce
n'est pas à la société disait-il de
fournir les moyens de se suicider si la
chose arrive pourquoi pas je ne sais pas
moi-même ce que je ferais un jour si un
de mes amis très mon épouse même va me
demander de l'aide pour la suicide je ne
sais pas peut-être que je vais céder par
amour à cette sollicitation mais une
chose me paraît évidente c'est que si je
le fais je sais que je transgresse la
loi et je ne souhaite pas que la loi
soit modifiée parce que je l'aurais
transgressé et donc il faudra que je
rende compte de mon acte et j'espère
l'indulgence des tribunaux devant les
tribunaux civils mais aussi le tribunal
de ma conscience donc est-il bien utile
toujours de légiférer
et bien je rejoins ici l'un de mes
maîtres je suis probablement le doyen
des quatre invités d'aujourd'hui et j'ai
eu la joie le plaisir de
travailler avec
Georges candilhem alors je tends Guilhem
un jour s'est exprimé sur cette question
Georges combinais mais il était médecin
et philosophe c'était pour nous une
grande référence en matière de réflexion
sur la santé George quand il aime a eu
cette formule en ses affaires compliqué
ou quelquefois le médecin se trouve seul
à seul avec son patient et bien il est
nocif de légiférer il peut être nocif de
légiférer
l'autre grand philosophe auquel je dois
beaucoup c'est Paul Ricard je vais le
citer tout à l'heure mais auparavant
je voudrais mentionner ce grand juriste
du Code Napoléon Portalis qui disait
dans un siècle il n'y a qu'une trois ou
quatre lois qui sont destinées à
perdurer parce que on veut toujours
bricoler on s'aperçoit pas que chaque
fois qu'on modifie une loi on enclenche
des processus qu'on ne maîtrise plus
et rendez-vous compte nous en sommes
depuis le 9 juin 1999 le 4 mars 2002 le
22 avril 2005 et le 2 février 2016 nous
en sommes à quatre lois en 17 ans
laquelle va durer et nous voulons en
faire une cinquième est-ce bien
raisonnable est-ce bien utile
ne les différer qu'en tremblant disait
un autre grand juriste le doyen
Carbonnier et donc le législateur doit
aussi me semble-t-il savoir ce retenir
la loi la loi telle que je l'entends tel
que mon travail
universitaire autour de la philosophie
politique mena appris la loi elle est
générale c'est Aristote qui le dit et
c'est un fondateur je crois en la
matière la loi elle est générale si elle
commence il peut que ce soit à rentrer
dans les détails et bien elle n'est plus
exactement la loi lorsque la loi
Léonetti a été votée le 22 avril enfin
été promulgué le 22 avril 2005
ça allait sans doute puisque vous
connaissez tous ici le dossier que les
actes médicaux c'était l'article 1er ne
devait pas être poursuivi par une
obstination déraisonnable je trouvais la
formule excellente fallait-il aller plus
loin le législateur la cru en ajoutant
lorsque les traitements sont
disproportionnés
inutiles où n'ayant d'autres effets que
le maintien artificiel mais déjà c'est
rentré à mon avis dans quelque chose qui
va nous épargner ensuite le jugement le
jugement
déontologique du médecin le jugement
judiciaire du juge n'étant pas en ce
moment en train de confondre le
juridique et le judiciaire nous avons je
crois les éléments déjà bien avancés
pour résoudre bien des situations
place aux judiciaires place aussi à
l'éthique médicale au jugement en
situation
Paul Ricard dont j'annonçais tout à
l'heure que j'allais le citer m'a
énormément inscrit sur cette question
Paul Ricard est sans doute à ma
connaissance le seul grand philosophe de
la fin du 20e et du début du 21e à avoir
pris des heures et des heures pour
connaître de l'intérieur la
problématique de la fin de vie il s'est
documenté il s'est renseigné la même
encadrédient sur les soins palliatifs
parce que ce qui est
en béton dans ce débat c'est que c'est
comme si on avait d'un côté la
revendication d'autonomie d'autonomiste
de d'individus et de l'autre
la difficulté à recevoir cette demande
alors que bien sûr il faut toujours
l'écouter et c'est comme si on oubliait
qu'en réalité
le point principal à mes yeux du code de
la santé publique c'est l'article 1111-4
issu de la loi du 4 mars 2002 et qui dit
très exactement et très littéralement
toute personne prend avec le personnel
de santé le professionnel de santé et
compte tenu de ces informations et
préconisations les décisions qui
concernent sa santé qui concerne sa
santé
c'est bien la personne qui
ultimement doit consentir à ce qui lui
est proposé qu'il s'agit d'examens
diagnostic ou qu'il s'agisse de
traitement thérapeutique mais
l'important ici n'est pas de dire qu'on
est passé d'un paternalisme médical qui
décide de souverainement de ce qui était
bon pour le patient un consumérisme
médical où l'on verrait le patient
décider souverainement de ce qui est bon
pour lui on est dans une alliance une
alliance thérapeutique et ce dont
témoigne ce texte magnifique il y a
aucun spage à dire autant que le premier
chapitre de mon ami André
ce dont témoigne les très organisations
que je mentionnais tout à l'heure c'est
précisément de cette alliance
thérapeutique ils savent si bien nouer
et ils savent nous dire de l'intérieur
que lorsque la culture palliative est
bien avancée que lorsque la formation
est bien faite et bien les exceptions ne
sont plus que de
0,3% la solitude chiffrée que je
connaisse donne ce chiffre de demande
d'euthanasie qui persiste alors 95%, 90%
des biens portants veulent la
légalisation de l'euthanasie mais
0,3% qui sont réellement dans la
situation et qu'évidemment aucun sondage
n'ira testé ce serait indécent mais on
peut au moins écouter les équipes
soignantes et bien 0,3% la réclame et
encore il faudrait voir à chaque fois
alors encore une fois interdire ça n'est
pas empêché et c'est là que je crois que
il ne faut pas que la loi se mêle de
trop de choses et il faut laisser faire
ce que j'appelle la conscience morale et
aussi le jugement du juge alors j'ai
préparé la citation de Paul Ricard que
je voulais vous donner elle est pour moi
une boussole s'il faut avouer j'ai eu la
chance le privilège à m'entretenir
beaucoup avec lui de cette question s'il
faut avouer que les pratiques
clandestines d'euthanasie
sont iné radicables ce que je crois dont
aucun pays la loi n'a empêché les zones
grises et même on peut aller plus loin
selon les deux études scientifiques dont
je dispose l'une des temps de l'anglais
l'autre est en français il y a plus de
tanasie clandestine en Belgique
proportionnellement la population qu'il
y en a en France il y en a en France
bien entendu s'il faut avouer que les
pratiques clandestines d'euthanasie
active sont inéradicables et si
l'éthique de détresse est confronté à
des situations où le choix n'est pas
entre le bien et le mal mais entre le
mal et le pire alors même le législateur
ne saurait donner sa caution le
législateur ne saurait donner sa caution
et il ajoutait Paul Ricard a-t-on oublié
la réflexion d'Aristote sur l'équité
confié au sage lorsque la loi trop
abstraite et trop générale ne peut plus
prononcer une parole de justice dans une
situation concrète marquée par l'urgence
et la détresse
le dernier philosophe que j'aimerais
citer c'est Chesterton philosophe
britanniques qui dans un livre sur le
génisme paru en 1922 avait eu cette
formule que j'ai voulu placer enfin
en épigraphe du livre que j'ai préfacé
de soignants belge qui disent pourquoi
ils ne pratiquent pas l'euthanasie
l'euthanasie l'envers du décor je
l'offrirai au rapporteur j'ai voulu
placer cette phrase de Chesterton qui
dit une loi produit toujours des fruits
bien au-delà de ce que l'avait cru
circonscrit au départ il le disait déjà
à propos de l'eugénisme en 1922 il le
redirait nécessairement aujourd'hui ce
que je redoute c'est que en répondant à
une demande
que je ne conteste pas dans le corps
social mais qui n'est pas une demande
médicale des personnes réellement dans
l'immense majorité des cas en souffrance
en répondant à une demande on crée en
même temps une offre qu'il ne soit
permis ici de dire que dans les pas de
ma maman a décidé d'aller elle va avoir
100 ans bientôt si jamais d'aventure
elle apprend que c'est une offre qu'on
lui fait parce que forcément elle lit
les journaux elle regarde la télévision
comment moi son fils mes frères et
soeurs qui l'accompagnant au quotidien
nous allons nous
continuer à lui donner le goût de vivre
ce qui pourtant est pour un fils par
rapport à sa mère vous en conviendrez le
non seulement un devoir mais tout
simplement la preuve d'affection que
nous devons je redoute que la
normalisation des esprits qui est en
cours en ce moment au Canada en
particulier ou 7% des décès sont
pratiqués par euthanasie
en Belgique où ça croit régulièrement ou
les restrictions de départ sautent les
unes après les autres je redoute que en
effet nous rentrions dans une
civilisation qui n'est pas celle que
Michel vaccès que je veux encore citer
ici un peu lourdement parce que un
atelier de gauche est quand même
quelqu'un qui n'est pas suspect de
rouler pour le Vatican et donc je trouve
que il faut faire attention à ce que
l'on est en train de mettre en place en
matière de modification de nos
représentations voilà je vais pas abuser
davantage du temps de parole mais
j'aurais plaisir à dialoguer et avec les
sénateurs et surtout aussi avec mes
collègues
merci beaucoup alors j'ai pas mal de
collègues qui souhaitent poser question
soit vous les adressez à un intervenant
particuliers soit c'est une demande plus
générale
on va prendre on va prendre des
questions ensuite chacun pour réagir et
peut-être certaines se regrouperont
Brigitte micolot ensuite filé mouiller
Vérone victoire jasmin et Jocelyne
guidez Brigitte
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur conte Sponville vous avez dans
l'article du Monde du 11 mars je vous
cite 10 il y a quelques circonstances ou
le droit au suicide devrait être
garantie certaines maladies très graves
incurable le handicap lourd ou l'extrême
vieillesse ma question c'est comment si
notre législation évoluait
pourrait-on établir clairement les
situations où le suicide assisté
pourrait devenir légal
j'ai mis une seconde
une grande majorité de nos concitoyens
et je mets bien le mets bien en
conditionnel
serait favorable à l'euthanasie est-ce
également une grande majorité du corps
médical et des enseignants
et si notre législation évoluée vous
estimez que la clause de conscience
serait indispensable ne serait ne
sera-t-elle pas
invoquer par une
majorité de soignants
merci Philippe mouillé merci madame le
Président j'ai deux remarques globales
la première on évoque depuis ce matin la
notion de droit de droit à mourir de
droit au suicide qui dit droit de
forcément pour l'état des obligations
des obligations de l'organiser que ce
soit dans le domaine public ou voir même
dans le domaine privé je pense à des
sociétés en Belgique notamment il y a
des soucises privées qui dansent leur
activité commerciale ça veut dire aussi
que à un moment donné il faut former des
professionnels parce que même si donner
la mort pour un médecin peut sembler
techniquement
entre guillemets aisé il faut s'y former
parce qu'il faut un accompagnement
psychologique donc ça veut dire mettre
en place une filiale de formation ça
veut dire d'ailleurs il y a des débats
d'assurance et comme la loi même si elle
est assez précise ne sera jamais n'ira
jamais dans le détail ça veut dire qu'on
ouvre aussi le champ de de de
difficultés d'interprétation et donc
forcément on va ouvrir le champ j'irai
de de contentieux autour de ce sujet là
donc ça veut dire qu'à un moment donné
il faut aller plus loin c'est
passablement que le droit c'est de avoir
tous les scénarios jusqu'à la notion du
contentieux quand tout le monde tu gères
le cantoncieux donc ça c'est une
première remarque parce qu'on va très
bien comme à un moment donné la loi
écrit l'administration précise et qu'en
fonction de qui pilotes le crayon et
bien l'interprétation peut aller
relativement loin notamment dans un
environnement qui peut être
politiquement perturbé donc jusqu'où on
va dans ce sujet là deuxième remarque
lorsque on écoute les partisans de ce
droit il y a souvent on donne souvent
des illustrations de cas extrêmes mais
comme ça a été dit qui représente
finalement peu de personnes mais il y a
des cas extrêmes c'est vrai et souvent
il y a deux termes qui reviennent
toujours c'est la notion de souffrance
et la notion d'être je vais mettre la
charge de la famille je vais pas caca à
charge
donc ça veut dire que le premier volet
on dit j'ai une souffrance la souffrance
physique on la comprend surtout qu'on
est en fin de vie la souffrance
psychologique elle existe mais elle
renvoie une définition c'est une
souffrance par rapport à qui par rapport
à quoi et donc ça renvoie aussi la des
nouveaux un vrai débat sur la motivation
la souffrance renvoie qui se renvoie
quoi deuxième point je ne veux plus être
une charge donc ça veut dire qu'on
légifère pour modifier fondamentalement
le principe de notre société que la
personne vieillissant tout mourante ne
peut potentiellement ne plus être une
charge petite charge pour cette famille
donc ça on va quand même des fondements
de droit et de principe généreux pour
une société tu ne plus seras plus une
charge pour ta famille c'est-à-dire que
alors charge morale
charge matériel et pourquoi pas charges
financière je ne serai plus une charge
pour ma famille et à partir de là
j'active un droit à être accompagné ou
un droit à mourir voilà donc c'est des
remarques globales parce que je pense
qu'au-delà de l'aspect parfois certes
philosophique était présenté ou parfois
technique ça renvoie des fondamentaux
essentiels de notre société cette notion
de ne plus être une charge d'avoir un
droit et donc voilà je trouve que c'est
globalement plutôt effrayant
merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente je vous remercie tous pour
vos interventions et moi j'étais en fait
dans une réflexion je n'ai pas de
question précise mais en tout cas les
interventions météo parce que dans les
conditions actuelles
de fonctionnement des hôpitaux avec les
moyens humains et matériels qui sont
quasiment inexistants pas suffisamment
en tout cas et bien les dimanches que
vous avez plus ou moins préconisés à
certains moments pour les praticiens
mais aussi pour les familles et les
personnels même les personnes concernées
mais je me pose la question
est-ce que dans le contexte actuel
on se projette sur des démarches qui
s'apparente quelques fois à des
maltraitances sanitaires simplement
parce qu'on l'a vu il y a deux ans il y
a quelques pas si longtemps comment
l'utilisation du Rivotril comment on a
on a permis de sédation
sans des procédures exactes en fait donc
qu'est-ce que là dans la démarche qui
sera la nôtre est-ce que nous sommes
vraiment conscients de
ce qui pourrait se passer
parce que les parents disons n'aura pas
forcément suffisamment de médecins
suffisamment de personnes en capacité de
travailler de façon consciente je dirais
parce que aujourd'hui dans les hôpitaux
que ce soit dans les établissements
publics ou privés d'ailleurs et bien
c'est compliqué c'est compliqué de
prendre des décisions c'est compliqué
d'appliquer certaines procédures et même
pour tous ceux qui étaient dans une
image de certification on voit bien que
aujourd'hui la situation est
catastrophique donc voilà ce sont des
questions que je me pose je n'ai pas de
je n'attends pas de réponse particulière
mais là je suis le département où les
données démographiques prouvent que
beaucoup de personnes sont de plus en
plus âgées de toute façon ce sera une
majorité et c'est déjà le pratiquement
le cas donc je m'interroge sur toute
cette démarche et toutes les
préconisations que vous faites est-ce
que
c'est raisonnable est-ce que
les personnes concernées d'autres ont
des choix finalement parce que
quelquefois pour eux sans même qu'ils
aient conscience qu'on a choisi pour eux
voilà merci
Jocelyne guidez
oui merci Madame merci messieurs pour
vos interventions très diverses du coup
on y perd un peu son sur latin laissez
mourir et d'en faire mourir c'est une
question importante mais pas facile d'y
répondre moi je voudrais parler des
familles la mort en tous les cas on en
parle pas beaucoup dans les familles ça
reste encore très tabou la campagnement
des familles quant à un membre va partir
est important je voudrais savoir ce que
vous en pensez avant de parler de
d'intervenir en tous les cas sur
l'euthanasie ou pas pensez-vous qu'il
est qu'elle est suffisante aujourd'hui
cet accompagnement 24 départements sont
dépourvus de soins palliatifs et par
conséquent la personne qui n'a plus de
toute sa tête ne veut pas toujours en
toute dignité moi je parle de dignité
voilà partir en toute dignité et dans de
bonnes conditions et l'image que ça
donne aux familles est désastreuses
comment pourrait-on garantir donc
l'accès de chacun des soins palliatifs
ou un accompagnement de fin de vie quel
que soit sa pathologie et son lieu de
vie fait respecter la loi néolithique
sur toutes les sur tous les territoires
avant de parler de d'euthanasie voilà je
veux dire aujourd'hui il y a une loi
quand même qui existe mais sauf qu'on
est même pas capable de la faire
respecter sur tous les territoires merci
à vous
merci bon il faut concentrer les
questions sur
l'aspect plus philosophique même si
j'entends bien en effet la préoccupation
qui a évoqué Jocelyne guidez il y aura
des tables ronds de juristes
et de médecins en plénière de façon à ce
qu'on puisse voir tous les volets là on
est vraiment en effet sur les notions
plus philosophique de la liberté
individuelle notamment Laurence Cohen on
va prendre toutes les questions
merci madame la Présidente moi je
remercie
chaque orateur et l'oratrice qui qui
nous a exposé qui nous ont exposés
pardon leur leur
philosophie
je pense que c'est un sujet extrêmement
délicat parce que on est ici en tant que
législateur mais en fait c'est interroge
l'intime
et c'est très compliqué de ne pas de
faire une espèce de d'étanchéité entre
les deux parce que c'est quand même une
question très personnelle qui renvoie
effectivement en tout cas moi
j'appartiens en groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologiste et je
peux dire que je ne suis pas sûr que
nous ayons une une position commune sur
ce sujet elle sera elle sera plus réelle
et je pense que c'est vrai dans tous les
groupes je ne crois pas qu'il y ait une
uniformité de point de vue parce
qu'effectivement pour moi ça n'est pas
une position idéologique pas du tout
c'est une question
personnelle c'est une question de de
certainement il y a une part de de
religieux pour certains mais même quand
on est athée comme moi il y a une part
de de ces paroles religieux mais il y a
une part de conviction de voilà donc
c'est ce que je veux souligner moi je
suis un peu gênée par le fait de devoir
légiférer je trouve que de plus en plus
on doit légiférer
et ça m'interroge ça m'interroge et en
même temps disant ça je serai hypocrite
de ne pas aller jusqu'au bout de ce que
je pense c'est que on est quand même
un moment donné obligé de cadrer les
choses pour éviter justement
éventuellement des dérives d'un côté
pour éviter des dérives et de l'autre
côté vous avez été plusieurs à parler de
proches
que vous avez dû assister je crois qu'on
est tout et tous confrontés à ce à cette
réalité et c'est toujours extrêmement là
aussi douloureux parce que pour les
expériences qu'on peut avoir en tout cas
moi c'est ce qui m'est arrivé ce sont
des appels à l'aide
auxquelles on ne peut pas répondre
et notamment pour ce qui me concerne
c'était une demande de mourir qui n'a
pas été respecté
et dont on est obligé de faire un lien
aussi avec les structures et je rejoins
victoire quand elle parle d'insuffisance
de moyens donnés aux soins palliatifs
donc on est obligé aussi d'en parler
quand une personne demande
le droit de mourir et que ce qui lui est
répondu c'est d'adoucir
la fin mais de ne pas de faire perdurer
ce temps qui est extrêmement long à ce
moment là et que vous vous êtes là en
accompagnant c'est terrible
l'impuissance est terrible l'impuissance
est terrible pour celui et celle qui
accompagne mais la douleur est bien plus
forte pour celui qui va partir ou celle
qui va partir donc je pense qu'il faut
légiférer et moi ma conviction c'est
plus de considérer que c'est une liberté
et qu'il faut laisser la liberté à
chacun chacune et créer les conditions
de l'égalité face à cette liberté parce
qu'il peut y en avoir effectivement
effectivement qui parce qu'ils ont plus
de moyens de connaissances de de
liens avec tel ou tel personne
auront la possibilité de se procurer les
produits qui leur permettront de partir
et d'autres pas donc voilà je suis plus
en contradiction avec des des aspects
qui sont à la fois personnels et en même
temps le besoin de cadrage en
finissant en disant quand même que la
loi la loi classe Leonetti est aussi en
tout cas pour toutes les expériences et
tous les retours que j'ai
particulièrement inconnu et on a eu
plusieurs madame la Présidente on a
travaillé sur ces questions-là et à
chaque fois il y a une méconnaissance de
cette loi c'est-à-dire elle n'est pas
appliquée dans toute sa plénitude donc
c'est aussi un problème je vous remercie
Laurent Burgoa ensuite à la Milan et
olivierno pour merci Madame merci à tous
et orateurs
je crois qu'il était bien d'entendre de
manière forte de dire que la loi est
générale je crois que c'est important
pour nous législateur d'entendre cela
parce que dans ce domaine si particulier
si intime je crois que on peut pas
généraliser à des cas particuliers la
fin de vie c'est pour chacune des
personnes c'est un cas particulier moi
j'ai beaucoup apprécié nous dire que
nous les gestateurs on doit avant tout
réaliser la loi et la loi elle est
générale comme on sait chacun des
juristes j'allais dire que à travers
cela bien que dans notre société je
crois que beaucoup certaines
législateurs mais je crois également
beaucoup de nos concitoyens confondent
lois et morale et donc mes questions
étaient doubles c'est toutes les lois
sont-elles morales
et la morale doit-elle être toujours
légalisée
[Musique]
merci pour ces propos particulièrement
clairs il y a longtemps que j'avais pas
passé une aussi bonne matinée à mercredi
matin
parce que je suis assez
je vous rejoins complètement quand vous
dites que les parlementaires sont
indemnisés pour faire la loi et pas pour
les multiplier et je suis là
complètement d'accord avec ça je
voudrais dire que nous avons voté il y a
quelques temps en arrière donc la loi
Clayes lyonneti et dans la dans le
premier article de la loi claye-sioletti
il est dit il doit y avoir
l'installation de service de soins
palliatifs sur tout le territoire
national je me souviens le tout le
territoire national c'est une Stan
amendement du Sénat
or il se trouve que s'il y a des soins
palliatifs un peu partout maintenant les
soins palliatifs ne sont pas mis en
place comme ils devraient l'être car à
mon avis et un autre avis à tous les
soins palliatifs c'est l'accompagnement
du patient depuis le début de sa maladie
et pas enfin de sa maladie et si le
patient était accompagné dans les
maladies graves bien sûr dès le début sa
maladie nous aurons peut-être pas le
problème qui se pose actuellement sur
l'euthanasie ou sur la fin de vie ça je
tenais à le dire d'abord et avant merci
à nouveau pour l'ensemble des propos que
vous avez tenus enfin je voudrais
revenir sur certaines choses qui ont été
dites vous avez différencié à juste
raison suicide assister et euthanasie
mais moi je me pose une question comment
être sûr de la plénitude des moyens
intellectuels du demandeur
ça c'est la première question que je
vous pose ensuite je vous ai entendu
parler de dignité et de liberté j'ai
noté sur mon papier excusez-moi mais je
n'ai pas trouvé d'autres termes nous
sommes en train de subir la dictature de
la philosophie pardon pour le terme
dictature il est peut-être un peu fort
mais pourquoi opposer dignité liberté on
a tous notre propre image de notre
propre dignité et si nous les médecins
puisque j'ai été au siècle dernier
médecin on a
on a la liberté de tuer on attend on
attend la dignité
merci pour la qualité de ces exposés je
pense que ils sont toujours beaux nos
mercredi matin
mais celui-ci peut être un peu plus
grave peut-être un peu plus un peu plus
grave moi lors de la loi de ce
bioéthique j'avais été assez
bousculé par un propos du professeur
delfresci qui avait dit on meurt mal en
France bon et c'est vrai que déjà la
question se pose des soins palliatifs
dans tout le territoire et quand on
approfondit aussi on voit que beaucoup
de gens voudraient mourir chez eux donc
se posera la question des soins
palliatifs elle se posent déjà il y a
déjà des réponses mais des soins
palliatifs à domicile
maintenant sur cette
grave question oui
il y a la question de la souffrance et
de la question de la charge mais il me
semble aussi que la question quand on
avance dans le débat de la de la dignité
de l'autonomie et il me semble que le
regard et ça c'est la question
fondamentale c'est bien c'est pas bien
c'est pas le sujet mais il me semble que
le regard que les uns et les autres nous
portons sur la mort et peut-être en
train de changer et un certain nombre de
personnes
créent moins la mort que de vivre sans
autonomie et sans dignité et moi j'ai
vécu ça de très près avec mon père voilà
il avait 82 ans il était encore assez en
forme mais il voyait arriver la fin de
la dignité l'autonomie
et il est parti en paix et pourquoi
a-t-il pu le faire parce que la loi
Claisse leetti lui a permis de le faire
il avait une insuffisance respiratoire à
un moment donné et il a demandé que on
arrête le respirateur et on a donc été
appelé ma soeur et moi pour essayer de
le convaincre de ne pas le faire
c'est la loi actuelle
et collectivement entouré d'un médecin
et lui en toute lucidité il a dit il est
l'heure pour moi et il est parti en
tranquillité mais s'il n'avait pas eu
cette insuffisance respiratoire alors il
pouvait pas faire ce choix
et là et là depuis ce temps-là et mon
interrogation et voyez quand on regarde
et quand on reçoit les uns les autres
nous on est près de la Belgique il y a
quand même quelques personnes qui font
le choix de regarder en Belgique ou de
regarder ailleurs et alors à ce moment
là si on aborde pas ce sujet se pose la
question exprimée par Laurence Cohen de
l'égalité parce que tout le monde n'a
pas les moyens de faire ça et donc voyez
on est on est bousculé par tout par tous
ces sujets moi originellement catholique
je regarde ces sujets avec les mains
tremblantes effectivement mais je les
regarde quand même et la question que je
pose au philosophe au fond est-ce que on
n'a pas un regard un peu plus tranquille
qu'autrefois peu à peu sur la question
de la mort est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
pas un changement anthropologique par
rapport à cette question et que
certaines personnes avec comment dire
en toute en toute en toute force
intérieure préfère la mort tranquille
que de vivre non pas parce qu'il y a la
question de la souffrance et de la
charge mais parce qu'il y a la question
de la dignité et de l'autonomie je vous
remercie
merci présidente merci madame messieurs
pour ces éclairages que vous nous donnez
c'est vrai qu'on a tous nos expériences
personnelles dans nos familles dans nos
amis qui nous amènent à nous poser
certaines questions moi je suis élue
dans le département du Doubs dans le
département du Doubs il y avait une
députée qui s'appelait Paulette
Guinchard künsler qui a fait beaucoup
pour les personnes âgées pour la
dépendance et qui du temps où elle était
ministre a toujours refusé
et de légiférer elle était contre cette
aide active à mourir ou se suicide
assister ou voilà mais quand elle a été
elle-même confrontée à la maladie et
qu'elle s'est vu
elle a demandé à partir à l'étranger
pour qu'on l'aide justement à finir ses
jours dans les conditions qu'elle a
choisies et ça c'est quelque chose qui
m'interpelle déjà moi je suis à titre
personnel plutôt favorable et j'ai bien
aimé monsieur constonville cette sur
liberté et pour moi je le vois comme ça
c'est une liberté c'est un choix qu'on
peut donner à certaines personnes de
dire bah maintenant voilà j'ai choisi
j'ai voulu vivre mais je veux aussi
choisir de partir et j'ai une question à
vous poser quand on parlait justement et
tu en as parlé
Olivier de ces personnes qui sont
dépendantes qui se sentent être une
charge pour leur famille ou pour leur
entourage comment est-ce que finalement
les médecins vous pouvez arriver à faire
la distinction entre le réel souhait de
mourir et cette notion de charge pour
les pour la famille ou pour la société
est-ce que on peut faire une distinction
et ce qu'on peut à ce moment-là aussi
aider les gens à y voir plus clair et la
deuxième question
j'ai été assez frappée il y a une jeune
fille en Bruxelles à Bruxelles en
Belgique je crois de 23 ans qui a
demandé aussi à être à être aidé pour
mourir parce qu'elle avait des problèmes
psychologiques suite à un très fort choc
émotionnel et ça m'interpelle de me dire
autant je comprends un peu plus
facilement quand il y a vraiment une
souffrance physique mais là je me dis
voilà comment est-ce qu'on peut limiter
est-ce qu'il peut pas y avoir des
dérives après parce que je pense enfin
c'est peut-être un peu mais je pense que
les souffrances psychiques sont
peut-être plus difficiles à
identifier donc comment est-ce qu'on
peut mettre aussi des limites par
rapport à ça voilà merci bon beaucoup de
remarques voire de questions
on recommence dans le moment parce que
je crois que vous avez un impératif
j'ai une obligation
en fin de matinée alors des questions
extrêmement riches et je vais remercier
les personnes qui se sont exprimées
après moi j'ai appris beaucoup et tout à
fait passionnant
je suis venu vous parler dans le cadre
dans un cadre relativement défini il
s'agit de donner une opinion ou même
faire une proposition de loi ou alors
une résolution de nos lois sur un sujet
qui est quand même parfaitement cadré en
tout cas ça a été la demande du
Président de la République la mission
adressée à la Commission des Citoyens
c'est-à-dire savoir si la loi Leonetti
peut-être complétée ou reprise pour des
cas bien spécifiés de personnes qui sont
affectées de maladies graves et
incurables c'est bien de cela qu'il
s'agit simplement qui ne sont pas tout à
fait au terme de leur vie et pour
lesquelles là l'application d'une
sédation profonde continue IR aussi ne
pourraient valoir ma médicalement ça ne
marcherait pas pour ces personnes là
soit qu'elles souhaitent arrêter un
traitement avec une un pronostic
fatal à court terme soit qu'elle
souhaite être aidé dans une démarche
finale il est clair que on est dans un
quand même un cas qui se situe dans un
accompagnement de fin de vie
incontestablement et pour raison
médicale donc vous les il est vrai que
la question de des souffrances
psychologiques est une question
extrêmement intéressante que la question
de de l'aide des familles de la part des
familles à une question absolument
décisive dans ce qui amène la personne à
apprendre sa décision et à l'exprimer
que la question des soins palliatifs
aussi mais là j'avais fait l'hypothèse
précisément que ces personnes qui
persistent dans leur volonté de mourir
bien qu'elle ne soit pas tout à fait au
terme de leur vie sont des personnes qui
auraient accès à des soins palliatifs
pour quelque sorte épuré le problème
particulier à traiter et en ne faisant
pas varier tous les paramètres à la fois
parce que après on ne sait plus du tout
sur quoi on peut apporter ou tenter
d'apporter un éclaircissement qui vaut
ce qu'il vaut mais enfin qui pourrait
être un éclaircissement
donc c'est dans ce cadre que se pose la
question d'une proposition de loi alors
j'ai été très sensible au remarques que
vous avez faites vous législateur sur le
ces espèces d'obligations de minimalisme
en matière de loi et en effet on le
connaît très bien trop de loi
contribuent à rendre la loi impuissante
maximise les risques de contradiction
entre des lois et souvent amène à
proposer une autre loi alors que la loi
déjà votée n'est pas appliquée et qu'on
n'a pas encore véritablement de retour
d'études d'enquêtes précis sur la
manière dont elle a été appropriée par
les personnes chargées de la mettre en
oeuvre et ensuite par les personnes
auxquelles elle pourrait s'appliquer
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce cadre qu'il me
semble que lorsque le léger 7 heures
vous collectivement prendrez une
décision de proposition de loi où on
serait amené à voter une loi proposée
par le gouvernement
ou à ne pas la voter en tout cas donner
votre opinion il est certain que la
cohérence avec l'ensemble du système
législatif des principes de nos codes
normatifs devraient être considéré alors
la thèse que j'ai exprimée au fond où
elle était relativement simple c'était
essayer d'apporter un éclairage
philosophique à ce qui doit
à ce qui peut éventuellement
contribuer à mieux définir ce que
pourrait être la portée d'une loi et cet
éclairage philosophique il me semble
absolument nécessaire parce qu'il est
lié à un certain nombre de principes
moraux qui sont incontestablement à la
base des systèmes normatifs les systèmes
légaux ne peuvent pas
en tout cas dans dans nos sociétés
libérales et démocratiques est
totalement en contradiction les inspire
même le principe de la du respect de
l'intégrité des droits humains de la
violabilité de la personne humaine de la
non commercialisation de la personne
humaine toutes ces princes tous ces
principes qui sont absolument qui
forment l'ossature du code pénal
français sont évidemment
inspirés par des par des valeurs morales
qui font le consensus en MATIF de nos
sociétés c'est quand même difficile de
le remettre en cause faut pas peut-être
leur reconnaître un caractère universel
on peut très bien imaginer des sociétés
qui fonctionnent pas comme ça des
sociétés dans l'histoire n'ont pas
fonctionné comme ça mais il reste que
pour nous c'est le cas donc je crois que
que tout une évolution de la loi qui
porterait atteinte à cela serait quand
même très difficilement envisageable
c'est la raison pour laquelle
bon alors droit et liberté bien sûr
évidemment une différence mais dans la
mesure où le droit à créer une
obligation d'exécution si c'est un droit
comme on dit aujourd'hui opposable qu'il
y ait un droit au suicide qui amènerait
une personne à exiger la reconnaissance
de suicide qui mènerait une personne
exigée qu'on lui donne les moyens
d'accomplir sa volonté et quelque chose
qui est aujourd'hui me semble-t-il assez
difficile à envisager la liberté de se
suicider personne ne l'a comptait je
vois pas d'ailleurs quelle autorité
pourrait la constituer une illégale
en tout cas on reste dans le monde de la
de l'imano c'est pas de la transcendance
en tout cas chacun a peut-être libre de
se suicider le suicide n'est pas
pénalisé en France donc la liberté est
acquise le droit et et est en question
et
d'autant plus qu'il s'agit pas dans la
loi de quelque chose qui s'appliquerait
aux malades ou à pas lui donner le droit
de demander il s'agirait bientôt
d'imposer aux soignants ou de de
permettre aux soignants sans poursuite
pénales de fournir les moyens de à la
personne de susciter c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit là très concrètement alors une
des pénalisation serait sans doute une
étape me semble-t-il et puis même un
terme beaucoup plus justifié que
légalisation au sens propre c'est à dire
que les actes de médecins qui fournira
la personne qui le demande les moyens de
se suicider ne seraient pas suivi de
poursuit ni même d'une instruction ça ça
me paraît une chose très importante j'ai
beaucoup insisté dans ce que j'ai dit
sur la valeur de de la de la
souveraineté de la personne de la
déclaration de sa volonté au moment où
elle commet où elle a accompli l'acte
c'est une chose très importante me
semble-t-il il faut que la personne soit
entièrement là maintenant votre
objection est tout à fait la objection
qui a été faite tout à l'heure et tout
avait justifié comment sait-on que la
personne est en pleine possession de ses
moyens et que son axe sa décision est
pleinement la sienne maintenant
j'aimerais vous demander dans laquelle
de nos décisions humaines peut-on dire
que la personne particulièrement
présente que les passions les sentiments
passés les attachements d'interfèrent
pas il est évident que les décisions
humaines sont une conjonction de de
multiples choses il y a des motivations
anciennes il y a des goûts il y a des
préférences il y a des habitudes qui
font que l'on demande qu'on dit vouloir
quelque chose demander une pureté
absolue de la de la de lucidité et de
possession de ces moyens intellectuels
dans la volonté de mettre fin à ces
jours c'est une demande à mon sens
totalement déraisonnable parce qu'on le
demande pour aucun autre de nos actes et
comme vous le savez tous les pays qui
ont essayé de dépénaliser certains cas
même de légaliser le suicide assistance
suicide il y a tout de même
des conversations avec le médecin le
médecin s'entretien avec la famille ce
n'est pas une volonté déclarée comme ça
qui est suivie des faits il y a tout de
même une évaluation de alors pas une
évaluation qui remettrait en cause la
liberté de la personne de manifester
volonté mais si les médecins estiment
que
la personne se trouve sous le choc d'une
disposition qui pourrait être amenée à
évoluer rapidement à ce moment-là dont
assez d'expérience et de
et de professionnels pour
approfondir la discussion et amener la
personne à réfléchir davantage à aux
raisons de le vouloir afin que tout
simplement qu'elle se l'approprie
pleinement une décision de d'être aidé à
mettre fin à ses jours même dans la
situation précise qui est celle évoquée
ici c'est à dire une personne qui est
quand même dans la dernière période de
sa vie doit être
certes aussi éclairé que possible que
possible dans la situation actuelle
parce que si elle était totalement
éclairée cette décision mais ça doit
être pas une décision de mourir enfin ça
va de soi c'est toute personne qui est
qui a délibéré sur ces choses là et déjà
dans une condition humaine tout à fait
particulière donc c'est essentiellement
sur ça que je voudrais insister et avec
les deux principes et à mon seul apport
philosophique que j'ai essayé de donner
et qui doit qui à mon sens un valeur
morale considérable c'est-à-dire la
liberté de la personne qui est
souveraine sur ce qui lui arrive elle
est la loi de 2012 a déjà reconnu
d'autres à la reconnu l'ont reconnu et
par ailleurs l'annonce d'intrusion de
truie ayant le fait que l'aide d'autrui
soit une aide indirecte et pas une
lettre directe je serai extrêmement
soucieuse une loi qui légaliserait
la possibilité d'administrer la mort
enfin ça me semble totalement
contradictoire à nos
à nos principes non seulement moraux
mais alors l'architecture même du code
pénal actuel donc je suis extrêmement
opposé à une légalisation de
l'euthanasie et même à une
dépénalisation de l'euthanasie dans le
sens où on l'a on l'a dit simplement on
peut pas se voiler la face simplement au
nom des principes et ignorer qu'il y a
des cas où la personne quoi inconsciente
a demandé à mourir la demander de
manière répétée sa famille peut attester
de la de la détermination de cette
résolution dans ces cas-là et bien on se
retrouve dans une situation qui est
celle d'aujourd'hui c'est à dire ou le
médecin se trouve responsable de sa
décision
alors évidemment c'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui quand les médecins décident
de donner à la personne ou la personne
étant inconsciente de proposer un moyen
où l'équipe médicale de de mettre un
terme à ce vide leur responsabilité est
engagée c'est absolument inévitable on
ne peut pas faire de cela un acte sans
sans intervention d'une décision humaine
il y a une décision humaine qui donne la
mort et la responsabilité doit être
prise maintenant il arrive dans des cas
comparables qu'il y ait une une
éventuellement pas de poursuite pénale
qu'il y ait une instruction rapide ou
l'équipe médicale apporte un certain
nombre d'éléments qui qui permettent de
délibérer de la question et de
reconnaître que la décision d'équipe
médicale au vu de la volonté exprimée du
patient de l'accord de sa famille était
la une décision qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas suivie qui n'est pas suiv i de
poursuites ça c'est tout à fait possible
mais on ne peut pas mettre cela sur le
même plan même au niveau de la
dépénalisation que les moyens de fournir
autrui ce qui lui permettra
avec ce qui lui reste de liberté de
volonté de mettre un terme à sa vie
j'avais prévenu que je devais partir moi
aussi à midi au plus tard donc pardon de
parler avant vous un mot rapidement sur
dignité liberté il s'agit pas d'opposer
les deux simplement ce que j'ai dit
c'est que l'Association pour le droit de
mourir dans la dignité se trompe sur le
vocabulaire parce que leur compréhension
qu'il veut dire il voulait dire que
certains de nos compatriotes meurent
dans des conditions indignes mais il va
de soi que tous les êtres humains étant
égaux en droit et en dignité le mourant
y compris s'il souffre atrocement a
exactement la même dignité que vous et
moi qui sommes pour l'instant en bonne
santé donc en effet ce n'est pas une
question de dignité c'est une question
de liberté deuxième observation
on n'est pas en situation de vie
juridique on n'est pas dans le silence
de la loi un médecin qui euthanasie
impatient il est coupable et donc
faisons pas comme si il faut pas
légiférer la mort et en dehors du droit
mais pas du tout puisque le Messie est
interdit et donc il y a une loi qui
règle qui règle la question et la loi
Léonetti au fond le précise en quelque
chose on n'est pas dans le silence de la
loi donc il est vrai qu'il faut légérer
le moins possible mais il faut parfois
malgré tout légitérer troisième
observation il y a bien sûr pas à
choisir entre les soins palliatifs et
l'euthanasie tout le monde est pour les
symptomatique pour le développement des
soins palliatifs et comme beaucoup
médecins me disent que mieux les soins
palliatifs sont faits plus la demande
d'euthanasie recule mais tant mieux bien
sûr je suis le premier à m'en féliciter
quatrième observation dans quelles
conditions est-ce qu'il faut on peut
rendre le système au suicide légal alors
d'abord
sur le fait qu'on n'est pas dans le
silence de la loi Robert Badinter qui
s'y connaît en termes de droit
constatait que le suicide En France
n'est pas un délice que Monique
rappelait et demander pourquoi
l'assistance au suicide en est un
paradoxe de condamner l'assistance de
considérer comme un délit l'assistance a
un acte qui n'est pas délictuel mais il
faut bien des limites pour autoriser
quelqu'un notamment un soignant à aider
son prochain à mourir autrement dit il
s'agit pas un adolescent car sa grain
d'amour qui demande à mourir on va pas
l'aider à mourir un adulte qui déprime
parce qu'il trouve que la vie n'a pas de
sens on va pas l'aider à mourir et donc
il ne faut autoriser l'assistance
médicale au suicide que dans des cas que
je porte la loi devra préciser mais pas
trop moi je vous en proposer trois le
handicap très lourd la maladie grave et
incurable l'extrême vieillesse mais je
ne suis pas législateur ça serait
évidemment à vous dans dans débattre
mais voilà il s'agit pas d'autoriser
n'importe quel suicide dans n'importe
quelle circonstance d'où la question du
droit
de mourir je ne vais pas je n'ai pas
revendiqué un droit à mourir j'ai
demandé le droit de mourir autrement dit
il faut faire une distinction entre ce
qu'on appelle les droits libertés le
droit de et les droits créances le droit
à par exemple j'ai le droit de voyager
personne que les droits libertés sont
définies par des interdits des devoirs
mais négatifs les droits créances sont
définis par des obligations donc si j'ai
le droit de voyager ça veut dire que
personne n'a le droit de m'en empêcher
si j'ai le droit de vivre ça veut dire
que personne n'a le droit de me tuer
mais c'est sur le droit à voyager c'est
que quelqu'un l'obligation de me
permettre matériellement de voyager si
j'ai le droit à vivre il faut que
quelqu'un m'assure que je ne mourrais
pas de faim de soif que sais-je c'est la
question du droit opposable au logement
que j'ai le droit de loger c'est une
vieille histoire toute personne a le
droit de m'empêcher de me loger si j'en
ai les moyens mais l'idée qu'il y a un
droit opposable au logement ça veut dire
que quelqu'un une obligation de me loger
et comme niveau ni moi nous sommes
décidés à loger nos contemporains ça va
être l'obligation de l'État ou du
collectif territorial ce qui est bien
plus commun pour tout le monde et bien
dans ce que je revendique ça n'est donc
pas un droit à la mort un droit à force
rien un droit opposable à mourir ce qui
serait idiot ce que je revendique c'est
le droit de mourir non pas un droit créé
un mais un droit liberté qui ne suppose
aucune obligation mais qui suppose un
interdit personne n'a le droit de
m'empêcher de mourir si je veux le faire
pour des raisons le fait qu'ils ne
relève pas d'une dépression d'un Sagra
d'amour pour des raisons que une
évaluation médicale comme disait Monique
pourrait trouver légitime et c'est
pourquoi la clause de conscience pour le
soignant est évidemment un point décisif
il est exclu d'obliger quel que
soitignant que ce soit à pratiquer une
euthanasie ou à aider un suicide si
c'est contraire à ces valeurs morales ou
ou religieuses voilà et donc en effet ce
n'est pas une question de dignité était
une question de liberté mais c'est
pourquoi c'est tellement important moi
je fais un libéral de quel droit est-ce
que la République
prétend limiter ma liberté quand elle ne
nuit aucunement à la liberté d'autrui il
y a quand même un paradoxe et dès lors
qu'on aime et la vie et la liberté on
souhaite que la vie soit libre jusqu'au
bout ça n'impose pas du tout le film je
n'ai aucune intention de me suicider je
préfère mourir dans mon sommeil bien
tranquillement mais si un jour je me
trouve paralysé des quatre membres
incontinence ou aveugle et les deux oui
là je demande effectivement d'avoir le
droit de mourir et je supplie la
République d'autoriser mon médecin à m'y
aider pardon de devoir vous quitter
prochainement
[Musique]
j'aurais voulu répondre rapidement à la
volée à toutes les questions il y avait
tellement de choses à dire merci en tout
cas mais tout de suite parce que à André
qu'on se prend vite parce qu'ils s'en va
vous avez parlé de l'IVG et de
l'euthanasie moi je mélange pas les deux
non bien sûr je vois une différence il y
a plein différents moi je suis un
praticien de la médecine et un praticien
du droit d'accord j'ai été prof de philo
c'est vrai mais bon
dans l'IVG on est pour on est contre
mais on peut facilement
identifier c'est prescrire par exemple
une pilule
abortive ou ça va être un geste abortif
dans un plateau technique donc
l'euthanasie est un geste qu'on peut
assez bien calibrer pardon vous voyez le
lapsus
qui m'a provoqué l'IVG l'IVG on peut
facilement l'identifier
moi ma grande crainte ça fait partie de
ce que je voulais dire en conclusion mon
ma grande crainte de praticien de la
médecine et aussi du droit c'est que
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué dans la
dimension médicale madame sénateur a
parlé tout à l'heure de la difficulté
dans certains hôpitaux à avoir des
protocoles des procédures des mélanges
et un manque de personnel de médecins
etc
je vous mets au défi dans ma pratique
quotidienne venez avec moi si vous
voulez un jour dans un tribunal faut pas
oublier que je suis l'exception qui
confirme la règle les avocats sont pas
médecin les magistrats sont pas médecin
je vous mets au défi dans certaines
affaires alors je parle pas des affaires
médiatiques qui sont évidemment
tragiquement caricatural puisque
évidemment ce pauvre Vincent Imbert
tétraplégique etc mais dans la vie
courante vous avez parlé du grand âge
moi je vois pas pourquoi le grand âge
qu'on a créé de toutes pièces et nous
les médecins qui avons créé le grand âge
en grande partie bien sûr il y a eu des
lois sur les travails sur la santé
l'alimentation etc mais c'est quand même
nous qui l'avons créé pourquoi
maintenant dire le grand âge maintenant
il doit partir parce qu'il coûte cher ou
une sert plus ou on aurait perdu la
dignité mon cher confrère on perd pas sa
dignité bon mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que c'est dans la pratique dans ma
pratique quotidienne André kosponville
mon drame il est là c'est que je vois
des situations où je suis avec
l'expérience
incapable il faut que je passe des
heures et des heures et des heures sur
un dossier pour trouver ici derrière le
départ du patient qui peut-être n'avait
demandé peut-être n'avait rien demandé
dans la famille se posait question la
question des familles si effectivement
il y a eu une intention
d'euthanasie ou pas c'est extrêmement
compliqué je vous mets en garde quel que
soit vos positions politiques
respectives ou croyances philosophiques
ou religieuses sur cette grande
différence
la demande de
d'IVG ça repose sur un constat simple
j'ai x semaines d'aménorrhée on fait un
certain nombre d'examens et on confirme
que je suis enceinte là il y a pas de
doute possible maintenant sur certaines
fins de vie que je vois autour de moi je
suis incapable dans certaines situations
de vous dire c'est très facile pour moi
de faire partir quelqu'un sans être
poursuivi je vais pas donner parce qu'on
est filmé on peut pas faire l'apologie
d'un certain nombre de choses mais
demain si je veux faire partir quelqu'un
je pourrais même avec Colombo contre moi
le faire partir sans être poursuivi
alors ça ça me pose problème André qu'on
Sponville parce que la clause de
conscience moi je préfère les
associations où on n'a pas de clauses de
conscience et je vais vous dire ce qui
se passerait si demain on vient voir
pour un acte d'euthanasie je ne
m'échapperai pas c'est à dire que je
verrai si je peux et doit y répondre
cependant moi ce que je veux ce que je
veux parce que c'est un principe
fondamental du droit c'est que si demain
pour X raisons pour ma mère ou pour un
de mes proches je commettais
délibérément en réponse à la personne
qui me le demande un acte de ta nazi je
veux que ce dossier là ce geste là soit
porté à la connaissance du procureur en
tout cas du parquet pour que en son âme
est conscience en vertu des règles de
droit etc etc il décide ou non 2
poursuivre ou de classer c'est-à-dire
que au nom de quoi nous médecins parce
que les patients souffrent etc
serions-nous autorisés à commettre des
gestes que nous ne maîtrisons pas
d'autant que la question s'est posée de
savoir c'est plus qui je crois que c'est
madame je sais plus sur la question de
étant jamais sûr qu'un patient est
réellement libre et éclairé on y Cantos
pervers a répondu je suis pas d'accord
avec sa réponse parce que il y a des
traitements rien que pour parler des
traitements je vous l'ai dit moi j'ai
les mains dans le cambouis je suis un
praticien il y a des traitements en
cancéro par exemple certaines
radiothérapies ou un des effets
secondaires c'est traduire une
dépression alors là c'est une question
d'épistémologie médicale en réponse pour
vivre faut-il considérer la dépression
dans cette situation du patient comme un
effet secondaire du médicament et dans
ce cas combattre par anticipation la
dépression par un antidépresseur ou
faut-il considérer la dépression qui par
exemple amène à demander à ce que ça
s'arrête comme l'expression libre d'une
conscience éclairée et informée à ce
stade de mon expérience médicale je suis
incapable de répondre donc pour moi je
veux bien qu'on discerte et il faut
disserter évidemment la philosophie à
cette noblesse mais dans au quotidien je
fais comment je fais comment André
konsponville quand je des situations où
tout le résumé d'un dossier médical de
700 pages qui va peut-être conduire
quelqu'un devant les tribunaux se résume
en une phrase du dossier médical et
parfois j'ai des dossiers où ça repose
sur une phrase parce que c'est vrai que
souvent les infirmières mettent bien
parce qu'elles sont beaucoup plus
précises dans leurs écritures que les
médecins donc moi je pense que c'est
extrêmement dangereux de dire on aura
toujours une clause de conscience moi
personnellement je m'en fiche la cloche
de conscience ce que je veux c'est
savoir ce à quoi j'ai à faire à qui j'ai
à faire à quel moment j'ai affaire et je
sais plus si je l'ai dit mais j'ai
rencontré vraiment dans ma situation une
personne une dame pour laquelle je suis
certain que la demande était fondée
qu'elle était libre et éclairée et après
c'est tellement compliqué je suis
entièrement d'accord avec Agnès Buzin
dans le monde du 17 mars qui parle des
dérives possibles nous sommes ici dans
un discours elle le dit de de bien
portant j'ai connu pour l'aide Guinchard
j'ai travaillé avec elle c'était une
femme absolument admirable qui avait été
de soignante qui connaissait le monde de
l'hôpital mais ce que vous dites c'est
ça prouve aussi que dans un sens un jour
on peut être contre et puis au moment de
passer de l'autre côté on peut être
favorable et l'inverse on pourrait aussi
citer Henri Caillavet etc etc bon j'ai
un jour quelqu'un qui m'a dit moi j'ai
militaire à fond pendant des années dans
la DMD association que je respecte mais
j'ai rencontré l'amour à plus de 80 ans
et donc maintenant je suis plus pressé
de partir c'est à dire que en fait il
faut laisser ouvert la possibilité voilà
et moi j'ai un mal je mets l'accent je
suis vraiment inquiet de ce que on ne
voit pas dans l'intérieur c'est-à-dire
de comment ça se passe vraiment dans la
prescription la prise en charge la
demande d'un patient est-ce qu'un
patient demande vraiment à mourir
peut-être qu'il veut sortir d'une
situation simplement difficile peut-être
qu'il a l'impression d'être un poids et
un charge et après moi je me dis qu'il y
a un curseur André kosponville il y a un
curseur qui m'inquiète vous avez parlé
du très grand âge mais c'est quoi le
très grand âge et pourquoi au nom de
quoi il devrait partir alors on fait
partie à 90 ans on fait partie
oui
je suis pas d'accord là dessus là je
suis pas d'accord avec vous vous dites
non non vous dites personne ne va le
tuer d'abord j'utilise pas ce mot qui
est connoté ou l'accorderez
idéologiquement mais
n'empêche que mais c'est très facile de
dire aujourd'hui une personne très âgée
moi je suis un rural dans ma région le
Pas-de-Calais monsieur sénateur parfois
aussi
qu'est-ce qu'on fait qu'est-ce qu'on
fait des personnes âgées on les met où
c'est quoi les structures qu'est-ce
qu'on a à leur offrir il y a certains
EHPAD qui sont encore hélas des mouroirs
donc est-ce qu'il y a pas une question
d'indignité de nos comportements de bien
portant à dire oh mais s'ils veulent
partir il faut répondre alors demande
moi je pense on sera d'accord j'en suis
certain que le vrai combat c'est un
combat pour une vie digne et un combat
qui pour une vie digne qui doit inclure
à un moment donné aussi la possibilité
d'une sortie digne ça je suis
entièrement je pense qu'on sera d'accord
mais pour le reste mais bon sang moi je
suis beaucoup plus prudent c'est pas si
c'est flou les frontières sont floues
alors mettez-vous à la place d'un
procureur et ensuite d'un juge il a fait
et instruite qui va dire mais alors là
j'y comprends rien c'est éminemment
complexe nos dossiers donc
là-dessus je suis très bon alors
monsieur le sénateur vous avez parlé de
effectivement des conséquences du droit
je pense un droit assurantiel les
contrats d'assurance vie demain les
contrats même d'assurance voiture etc on
voit bien déjà que si je suis sous
traitement alors je parle pas d'alcool
de cocaïne etc etc mais si je prends des
traitements antidépresseurs on voit bien
qu'il y a certains contrats où on remet
en cause etc que va devenir toutes les
conséquences pratiques de notre droit si
demain on l'égalise
alors la mort dans les familles ça a été
dit je pense qu'effectivement on
commence à prendre en charge mais c'est
pas suffisant c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il faut accompagner
bon enfin il y aurait beaucoup de choses
à dire toutes les lois sont-elles
morales et sur que non un état nazi une
dictature en général c'est pas une
dictature qui vit sans loi au contraire
il y a beaucoup de loi et je pense que
dans le système nazi il y avait c'est un
système éminemment juridique donc les
lois sont pas forcément morales
et en fait donc je vous lis je
terminerai juste là-dessus voilà
moi ce qui m'obsède parce que c'est une
obsession c'est pas une posture
idéologique je suis pas contre par
principe religieux philosophique ou
politique André kosporique je suis pas
contre pour ces raisons là je suis
contre parce que dans aucun des pays
dans lesquels l'euthanasie où a été a
été dépénalisé où légalisé on a pu
maîtriser les dérives et c'est ça mon
problème vous parlez d'un choix
individuel on dirait qu'on se prend vite
je suis d'accord et moi j'aimerais bien
si un jour je fais le choix pouvoir me
suicider si je peux pas le faire je sais
pas comment je ferai donc la question de
la liberté elle est fondamentale mais
j'aimerais pas que pour des raisons
idéologique politique
raciale
on choisit à ma place on choisit sans
que je sois informé et sans aussi que je
sois d'accord je vous affirme que en
dépit de la protection qu'offre la loi
leonétique en dépit des formations qui
restent insuffisantes il y a trop de
départements aussi mais il y a aussi un
problème de démographie médicale qui est
un problème qu'il faudra régler mais je
pense que il y a déjà
des dérives alors volontaire ou
involontaire donc je suis entièrement
d'accord que la question de la liberté
philosophique du choix du moment de sa
mort et certainement la question
philosophique par excellence ça on est
entièrement d'accord maintenant dans la
pratique je pense que c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus compliqué et j'attire
votre attention sur l'impossibilité si
vous allumez la mèche de maîtriser les
dérives
vous souhaitez compléter il nous reste
encore quelques minutes bien évidemment
avant que vous répondiez je voulais
préciser que les rapporteurs ne se sont
pas exprimés c'était en accord avec elle
pour laisser d'abord le débat assez long
de nos intervenants qui avaient des
choses passionnantes à nous dire et
qu'on bâcle pas cette partie là et aussi
pour laisser puisque là on est en
formation plein air pour laisser les
commissaires s'exprimer les rapporteurs
en l'occasion de faire beaucoup
d'auditions et elle se permettront si
vous en êtes d'accord de vous solliciter
éventuellement c'est des questions on
n'avait pas été évoquées monsieur Rico
merci madame la Présidente alors je vais
pas abuser du temps que que vous me
laissez ici parce que tout simplement
j'avais prévu que nous n'aurions pas le
temps et donc j'ai et donc j'ai envoyé
hier soir à nos administrateurs une
contribution écrite me permettant de
dire des choses que je n'ai pas le temps
de dire ici et puis j'offre rapporteur
pas à tout le monde mais j'offre d'une
part sur le livre dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure à l'envers du décor témoignage
de soignants belges qui nous ont demandé
de préfacer et puis j'offrirai aussi le
mien parce que moi c'est pas en 15 pages
c'est en 350 pages que j'ai essayé que
j'ai essayé de regarder la complexité de
la question où vous verrez d'ailleurs
dans ce livre Madame et Monsieur le
rapporteurs que je parle très peu de
l'euthanasie au bout du compte parce que
c'est vrai et c'est un poids d'accord
avec André kossosporville c'est pas la
question majeure que rencontre les
personnels soignants d'aujourd'hui la
question majeure elle est pas là elle
est dans l'obstination des raisonnable
elle est dans le soulagement de la
souffrance elle est dans l'insuffisance
de la pas simplement des unités sur
palliatives qui manquent dans 21
départements elle est dans l'absence
totale de culture palliative dans les
études médicales et paramédicales et
donc n'y a-t-il pas ici une urgence
absolue par rapport à la question qui a
été soulevée aujourd'hui alors des noms
ont été prononcés je voudrais redresser
parce que tout le monde commet la même
erreur Paulette Guinchard a toujours été
n'a jamais varié partisan du suicide
assisté regardez les propositions de loi
qu'elle a déposé elle était hostile à
l'euthanasie elle n'a pas changé d'avis
elle est allée en effet en Suisse alors
la question qui est régulièrement posée
alors c'est pas juste il y en a qui
peuvent aller en Suisse d'autres en
Belgique et c'est une question
d'inégalité totale dans tous les
compartiments de l'existence est-ce que
ça veut dire qu'il faut mettre des
mécanismes compensatoire pour ceux qui
ne peuvent pas aller en Suisse ou en
Belgique je trouve que ça supposerait
résolue la question de savoir si la
société trouve bien trouve très normal
que les gens se suicident moi
excusez-moi mais
avec les soignants au contact desquels
je travaille quand quelqu'un est
suicidaire on fait tout son possible
pour l'aider à retrouver un peu de
saveur à la vie et on ne considère pas
que notre métier notre travail c'est de
l'envoyer en Suisse cela dit une de mes
meilleures amies
à laisser son mari partir se suicident
en Suisse à la limite j'aurais été prêt
à financer le voyage si elle me l'avait
demandé en tant qu'ami mais en tant que
citoyen je me refuse vraiment à
organiser ainsi des voyages
gratuits remboursé par la Sécurité
Sociale donc la notion d'égalité je
crois qu'il faut y faire très très
attention et pas lui faire dire
n'importe quoi j'ai été sensible tout à
l'heure à un autre nom qui est passé
dans le débat c'est celui d'Henri
Caillavet
sachez mesdames et messieurs moi qui
suis très hostile à la dépénalisation du
suicide assisté et de la question nazie
que j'étais son ami et son ami intime et
qu'il m'a demandé de préfacer le roman
qu'il a voulu écrire à la fin de sa vie
et nous étions réellement amis
réellement il m'a raconté beaucoup de
choses que je ne dirais pas ici tant que
je les ai pas publiés mais voilà c'est
quelqu'un qui est toute sa a été quand
même encombré par le fait d'avoir tué
son père qui n'était ni en fin de vie ni
malade
ni en fin de vie ni malade il l'a tué et
je lui dis mais Henri est-ce que vous
auriez accepté de faire ça votre maman
ah non sûrement pas le père a été
tyrannique toute sa vie lui a interdit
de faire des études de philosophie
mais tout ça pour dire que méfiez-vous
des personnes dont on parle avec un peu
de suffisance et sont toujours bien
connaître les arrières fonds il avait
souhaité que j'aille à ses obsèques j'y
suis allé bien entendu et j'ai beaucoup
appris de lui et je crois que lui a
aussi beaucoup appris de moi
puisque alors j'ai promis que je serai
pas non
on a parlé de alors je prends les noms
qui sont venus Vincent Imbert Vincent
Humbert mais quelle histoire le tableau
clinique a fait André cantospanville ne
correspond pas la réalité médicale
sans kinésithérapeute vient de mourir il
y a deux mois j'étais en relation avec
lui en relation amicale depuis une
quinzaine d'années mais son
kinésithérapeute ainsi que son
ergothérapeute ainsi que son médecin
n'ont jamais eu le même discours que
celui qui a été médiatiquement imposé
certaines de certains autres essayistes
l'ont dit moi-même je l'ai dit dans des
publications antérieures à celle-ci mais
on n'est pas entendu parce qu'il y a un
discours unique qu'on doit tous entendre
il voulait mourir et ben le
kinésithérapeute dit exactement le
contraire et il l'a écrit et il n'a pas
été attaqué en justice pour avoir écrit
le contraire de ce que le discours
médiatique nous imposait combien de fois
les choses se produisent ainsi
j'ai dit que je ne tricherai pas puisque
je vous offre le livre et j'ai ma
contribution écrite mais la toute
dernière remarque c'est toujours pareil
c'est avec une personne j'ai le plaisir
de me retrouver en face de Michel
meunier dans mon département personne
que j'estime énormément j'étais non mais
j'étais j'étais
là encore quand on est vieux on a des
amis qui durent une des amitiés qui dure
plus longtemps peut-être j'étais l'ami
de guigoureux que vous connaissez bien
vous aussi qui était le bras droit de
Jean-Marc Ayrault à la première
municipalité que celui-ci a dirigé
et
digourou était atteint d'une maladie
mortelle incurable
et à l'âge de 2 ans on avait dit à sa
maman ne vous attachez pas à lui il
avait une tétralgie de Fallot tout le
monde mourait autour et en effet c'était
insupportable et puis finalement il a
survécu jusqu'à l'adolescence on a redit
la même chose il va mourir et puis il
est pas mort il est mort à 85 ans il a
été le président du groupe socialiste au
conseil général pendant quatre mandats
il a été le maire adjoint de Nantes le
problème le deuxième adjoint il a été
président de l'office de HLM il a été
vice doyen de
l'université de Nantes il a été
vice-président je veux dire il était
doyen de la facultation il a été papa
grand-père bref comme l'a dit son fils
le jour de ses obsèques mon père a été
en soins palliatif toute sa vie
autrement dit on peut atteindre d'un mal
incurable d'une maladie mortelle et être
soignée ça veut pas la même c'est pas la
même chose de dire qu'on va guérir mais
on peut être pris en soins moi je suis
résolument pour une société qui certes
développe l'éthique de l'autonomie je
suis pour la liberté à fond je pense
qu'il ne faut pas
juridiquement les gens ne se suicider
bien évidemment mais je pense en même
temps qu'une vraie société une société
digne de Snow est une société qui
reconfigure l'éthique de l'autonomie par
une éthique de la vulnérabilité c'est à
dire qu'il prend en compte qui prend en
considération la fragilité la faiblesse
de l'humain et je dirais le tragique de
la condition humaine qui de toute façon
quel que soit les lois que vous pourrez
voter sera jamais éliminé de nos
existences ayons les uns et les autres
philosophes législateur médecin cette
modestie de croire que le tragique est
inéliminable
merci beaucoup merci à vous deux et bien
évidemment à ceux qui sont déjà partis
mille merci pour cet éclairage et si
nous avons des questions complémentaires
monsieur Rico a anticipé nous
permettront les rapporteurs se
permettront de merci pour les livres
donc si vous conseille de lecture
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
à examiner de Katia ponceopoly ensuite
une désignation pour la CMP sur la pépin
de liste